the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
world-class chess is back in full force
at the super bet chess classic in
Bucharest Romania reinvigorated from the
rest day players were back at the boards
and ready to battle Wesley so had a
wounded ding laryn on the ropes but
unsure of his Advantage accepted a draw
Fabiano caruana put an end to olareza
farruges to win hot streak with a
Bittersweet draw to remain the sole
leader only three rounds left can
caruana run away with it day seven of
spectacular chess
coming up next
[Music]
foreign
welcome back everybody to day 7 of the
2023 Superbad chess Classic held in
beautiful Bucharest Romania we start the
day in one of the most scenic places
here in Bucharest the chismiju park as
we are very close to the playing venue I
am sure the players come here and relax
get their daily walks in just relax in
between the games now it's been a
fantastic event up to this point let's
go to the studio and start the action
for day 7.
we welcome you to the first step on the
2023 grandchild store and our coverage
of Superbad Romania we come to you live
from the San Luis chess club
foreign
[Music]
thanks for joining us again I'm
International Master nazipai kids and
I'm here with Grandmaster yeah
wonderful wonderful as always to be with
you and Vara calling the action it's
been great thus far how are you liking
it I'm loving it I'm loving it hello
everyone and Welcome to our live
broadcast of the super bet chess classic
round six five draws but boy were they
fighting draws two games could easily
easily have ended up in wins not no
changes in the standings but let's take
a look at the standings where do we as
we go into round seven right here's the
scores we have a soul leader Fabiano
caruano with four points and then close
the following alireza ferrugia leslisso
and Richard rapper nice three and a half
points
games yes and then we have uh two
players with 50 anishikiri and Maxima
Sheila Graf and with two and a half yeah
sure looks like a typo to see the
Challenger and Champion type for seven
yeah two points
nice and our format
we have a 10 player round robin
tournament with a classical time control
90 minutes for the first 40 moves 30
minutes for the rest of the game 30
second increment from move one
players not are not allowed to offer any
draws and we have a regular scoring
system with one point for a win half for
a drill and zero for a loss tournaments
motoring right along but tell us about
the remaining schedule
right we have three more rounds to go
today players will be playing round
seven and the tournament will end on
Monday May 15th
and we're very fortunate to have in
studio version good morning VAR uh tell
us about the players in their road ahead
good morning guys and yes we have three
rounds remaining and four players I
think have a shot to win this tournament
Fabiano is in Elite but let's take a
look at the road ahead for these players
who they gonna face in the remaining
three rounds
so
so where Wesley so he's playing a big
match today against Fabiano and then
he's playing uh Jan in around eight and
the last round he will play Duda so he
needs to try to get a chance to win this
gun the big game here in round seven
against Fabiano
then then we have firusha he is facing
uh Yan in round seven then he has Duda
and the last round he will play his
countrymen mvl he needs to try to win
one game out of the street to have a
shot
we have Fabiano here playing against
Wesley so round seven then he's got
Anish giri in round eight and last round
he's playing Richard report that could
be a very big game in round nine
and we're gonna go to Romania to our
colleague Grandmaster Christian chirilla
thanks Laura and welcome back chess fans
to day 7 here in Bucharest Romania at
the 2023 Superbad chess classic what an
event so far such a topsy-turvy event
back and forth between this amazing
player but I have to say yesterday in
round six as you mentioned yes sir two
of the players definitely left the
playing Hall disappointed and that is
Fabiano caruana and Wesley so who are
going to face each other in today's big
clash of the round as you guys already
covered Fabiano is leading but only by
half a point and we know how dangerous
Wesley can be and if he wants to win
this tournament Wesley with the white
pieces will have to pile on the pressure
on the young Fabiano caruana our leader
in the Superbad chess classic up to this
point five wins four losses and 29 draws
between this two players just an amazing
matchups I cannot wait to see what
they're going to bring over the
chessboard another big Clash that I'm
having my eyes on is the one between Ali
Reza firuja and Jan naponia and I have
to say this is mostly a clash of styles
in my opinion we've seen this matchup
play out quite a few times and I have to
say it was a young that usually was
besting Ali Reza and even here in
Bucharest last year with the black
pieces Jan managed to win against Ali
Reza fieruja that's because Jan is so
proficient in the opening phase of the
game that's surely due to the fact that
he spent many months preparing for not
one but two world championship title
defense defenses that is against Magnus
Carlson in Dubai and of course the
recently concluded one against the
England in Astana so he's extremely
strong in the opening phase of the game
and we've seen that alireza is deficient
at the beginning of the game that's due
to the fact that he doesn't have as much
experience he doesn't have as much time
of preparation behind him he's only 19
years of age so this one is definitely
going to be a clash of styles and we
know alireza he's motivated he's chasing
Fabiano caruana only half a point behind
he's confident due to the fact that he
managed to uh Escape yesterday against
the leader with the black pieces now
with the white pieces he's definitely
going to bring the fire to the
chessboard guys back to you in the
studio I cannot wait for these games to
begin thank you Christian to two great
matchups uh to be sure yes but tell our
viewers lay the table tell them what
they can expect into today's pairings
Nancy let's take a look at today's match
apps we have Duda against Maxima
shellegra again two players who
desperate for a win we have firusha
against nipom niche
and of course the biggest matchup Wesley
saw against Fabiano caruana that could
be a tournament decided right there we
have Geary against dink
struggling day I might ask that and
Rockford against dick
Richard
he's on the outside looking in if uh if
Wesley doesn't win and Richie you know
what I mean what I mean very exciting
and heart fights big fights in fact and
what are they
or I was about to ask about the prize
fun but I think we're just going to jump
to the playing Hall
all right what are they fighting for uh
all right the players fighting for a lot
of money yeah the price fund for this
event is 350 000 and the first place
winner is going to get a 100 000 second
place sixty five thousand third forty
eight thousand wonderful handsome uh
prize fund as you can see prizes all the
way down to 10 to final position the
grand Chester points up for grabs anyone
who can win the tournament clear Force
gets a grant a bonus Grand Chester
points so they would get 13. the tie for
first and they start sharing 12 a grand
Chester appoints the player who has the
most at the end of the tour wins a
hundred thousand bonus so grab your
grandchester of points early
at the opening ceremonial first move
I'm gonna guess a football player
Football manager football manager
[Applause]
if it's just me I don't know but it sure
looks like there's a lot more cameras on
stage a lot more TV cameras on stage it
seems like the Romanian press has
discovered our uniting minds super bet
tournament
they're excited because there's only
three rounds left right and they can't
miss out on the action exactly
now yesterday Nasi what did you think
about the interview with Wesley Wesley
really looked
defeated unhappy he misjudged the final
position badly and it was a shock
right uh this players rarely if ever
make mistakes so when they do it's it's
shocking to them right and really make
the Judgment mistakes so we'll see if he
recovers from that quickly what what
goes through your mind when you know you
left points on the table and it's the
next day are you still carrying
previous round with you I'm trying
really hard not to right it's in the
back of my mind yeah and I'm trying to
not think about it but it is there it is
there VAR what do you advise your
students who might have uh missed an
opportunity the day before the main
thing I think is just try to forget
about it and just try to take this as
it's like the round one new game
completely and just take it from there
otherwise if you just look back and
think about it during the game it
probably will affect your play in that
particular matchup exactly exactly but
we can't we can't help but I've never
said that exactly emphasize uh Wesley
half a point behind Bobby with the white
pieces if ever you need a win now's a
good time there's two players have 29
classical draws that's amazing they're
Head to Head how even they were five to
four that was just barely barely in
Wesley's favor kind of remarkable when
you think about Bobby as being a
challenger uh
by the way talking about Wesley having
missed something Fabby too Fabby too
he's kind of injured
uh-huh there was a little conversation
going on there between Richard and uh
diac as uh Richard
informed the opening ceremonial first
move go ahead play D4 Richard left it on
the board dayak said I want you to play
it I don't want that football manager
guy coming in here ruining the game take
responsibility
and let's see uh what opening has Wesley
chosen okay
always interesting to see what move
order D4 Knight F6 Knight F3 uh oh my
favorite oh Catalan C4 E6 G3 not a
surprise for Fabi as Wesley often plays
uh the Catalan but also nimso Indian
with Queen C2 classical G3 Bishop E7
intriguing no Bishop B4 check
um this time around probably usually VAR
Fab usually uh likes to play the open
Catalan and earlier in the tournament he
he faced the Catalan uh what do you
think he'll have prepared today
um I'm not sure exactly which line he
will play but against dink I remember
that game was very impressive yes he
equalized right out of the opening and
essentially forceding to repeat the
moves he had a nice time Advantage as
well but we know Wesley knows this
catalon lines very very well as well so
uh so now they just played counseling so
let's take a look what is the uh alter
lots of theory here guys lots of theory
counseling is by far the most popular
move Queen which he has played yeah
Queen C2 is another option here so the
question is now if he's gonna play uh
Knight bd7 he's going to take on C4
these are the main Alternatives here
he took yeah he took on C4 so we're
following the the very again there are
some options here for white in this
position so let's see Queen C2 playing
quickly right
A6
A6 has been
the most go-to move in this position
a2a4 and then why choosing between plane
A4 are taking on C4 and allowing B
exactly in my day the fashion was you
play Queen take C4 extraordinarily old
enough and a shout out to our friend
Guinness's Uncle he kind of glazed a
trail with a very remarkable move Bishop
D2 that like what on Earth is that and
it's a tricky trappy move the idea is
that black wants to play C5 but Knight
bd7 actually runs into the very awkward
Bishop A5 and you're not getting in the
break C7 C5 anytime soon so Bishop D2
used to be really uh what fashion was
all about today a2a4 I think mostly has
superseded Queen takes C4 wouldn't you
say far yeah absolutely a lot of A4
moves we see lately and now um in this
position Bishop D7 is actually uh the
very best move here for black to try to
play for this idea Bishop C6 and now
here Wesley is taking a little pause
here trying to decide which moves to
play Knight E5 is another alternative
here 95 Bishop C6 Knight takes c66
Knight C6 and uh
you have the bishop C6 ideas you can
play E3 here as well so he's trying to
figure out what to play this is the
interesting moment in a game here he can
also take on C4 okay he just took on C4
Queen C4 and
yeah against lots of theory here guys we
have about over 3 000 games played in
this position so still a lot of large
Theory ahead here okay we'll keep an eye
on this one let's just jump to the ever
creative inventor
he's our go-to guy when you want
something strange to appear on the board
well D4 at Knight F6 uh Bishop G5 I'm
just having him thank you uh the Trump
how dare I prefer for forget Giuliana
hodgson's favorite tronkovsky Bishop G5
D5
he didn't take it how interesting E2 E3
waited for the move C5 to take take
and well I'm not really familiar with
this one I guess it's uh it's still
Theory nothing changed there but Bishop
B5
uh I find that move a little bit
surprising is that the main move in this
position uh no no it's it's not the main
move in this position uh let's take a
look here so D takes C5 there are like
400 games 93 a couple hundred games as
well but after Bishop b58 so we only
have 18 games in a database here 18 18
yes and uh Knight C6 is the main move
out of those 18 Bishop D7 is also played
there is a game or a Savage porno Mario
looks like morosevic used to play this
as white and uh we have a game of uh
elshon moradia body against ATM backro
as well so but yeah looks like moroz
zevich's pet line he had a couple of
games he played in this with the white
pieces we do have on the board Bishop B5
Bishop D7 Bishop that's already appeared
and instant capture yes capture and here
it's just getting rid of both of his
Bishops yeah he did he did a great job
at trading off his Bishops uh Sydney
Bishop takes D7 and what's the state of
theory again on this very off-beaten
variation just four games played and
looks like you can capture with the
queen you can also capture with the
Knight the engines think black doesn't
have any problems here which is not
surprising because white really can't
achieve that much of an advantage by
playing the the trumpo skin it's a lot
of tempies as you can see Bishop G5
Bishop F6 now Bishop B5 Bishop a lot of
extra temp is white has spent there is
some advantage on the structure here
they're double pawns but overall I think
Black is Black is fine here
okay I like to jump to this game against
nepo I like alirez's approach I think uh
obviously we all know that Jan is
extremely well prepared in the openings
right so he chose this uh variation
that's not very theoretical and took him
out of the book early he did it's uh it
almost feels like a Queen's Gambit
declined in Reverse right like White's
played an early E2 E3 uh our friend
Arthur yusapov used to make a very very
good living playing in these positions
B2 B3 Bishop B2 Knight E5 I mean I don't
know how many Scouts uh he he won with
these very slow building attacking Moves
In this case D5 takes C4 okay E2 E3
A3 gosh now it looks like it's re gone
into a queen's uh yeah but accepted
reversed
um
are we still in theory as far as far
Asia and uh Nepal were concerned Devar
only one game actually only one only one
game I see in my database again I think
firusha is just trying to avoid the
theory just you know so a little bit
more actually I was just told uh in a
you know more comprehensive database the
chess base probably either six games so
leeches is just showing one so it's a
one game I have here it's a Anton gujaro
from Spain against volokitin two very
strong Grand Masters and that game ended
in a draw in this position so Knight bd2
was played in this position so the point
of 9 bd2 here is that if you capture you
can capture back with the Knight to uh
D2 to FD if you play the move Bishop B2
you're allowing this additional option
for black to capture your knight and
play this ship E5 move trying to
liquidate the Bishops and this is
something that you want to avoid in my
opinion because it'll be kind of hard to
get this before move in right so that's
why I think uh in that game Anton played
the move a knight bd2 first
and uh A5 was played
and B5
Knight E5
and Bishop B2 So eventually white is
going to be able to play C4 right and
engines are showing at this moment a
very slight Advantage for white
hmm all right thank you for that far and
let's jump to uh Bucharest and check in
with Christian
uh thanks uh yes well I don't know if
you guys caught this on camera but there
was a slight incident at uh the game
between uh Bogdan Daniel Dak with the
black pieces and Richie report Richie
um after making his first few moves he
got off from his seat very very angry he
started pacing around the playing hole
he went outside he uh talked to my
father who is in fact the one of the
Arbiters at the competition as well and
he told him that Bogdan is making his
moves and slapping the clock making a
lot of noise and disturbing him so uh
there's some tension in that game let's
not forget this is Romania's number one
and number two they're definitely you
know fighting for a position there's
that rivalry always existence so this
one quite an interesting moment Bogdan
definitely understood what was happening
the Arbiters did not tell him anything
they didn't have to to tell him anything
because the next move that he made he
just like gently pressed the clock
Bishop to D7 was that move after the
move Bishop to B5 we have a trumpovsky
on the board in that game a very very
exciting chess uh very intriguing game
and a lot of tension between these two
players
imagine the rivalries of number one
number two National Championship uh the
pride of representing the country in the
strongest event to take place in
Bucharest the tensions right and
sometimes the players just act a little
bit childish all this but yeah and
sometimes it's not intentional I know
most of the time it's not and it's sort
of like from the very beginning they got
you know on the wrong track in the sense
that hey take your uh Daniel is telling
him to take the move back and and that
that was the move that was played by by
the uh ceremonial
I didn't know I'm gonna start the clock
no handshake too by the way
and they were just confused what to do
they skipped their handshake yeah well
Richie's ass okay
um nice uh little uh pitter patter aside
I like to just jump into the game of
Duda versus mvl for a moment because
it's a Queen's Gambit accepted of sorts
the Pawn's still on D2 which kind of is
a little confounding but white is
preparing to play uh the break d2d4 so
we have a let us say a ready
yes exactly move order with Bishop takes
C4 E6 castles now here I would imagine
just about everybody plays D4 but
nothing's wrong with Queen E2 A7 A6 now
if you were going to make something out
of this uh Queens Gambit accepted you
kind of would think maybe A4 I don't
know maybe bishop B3 it'd be a little kg
Rook D1
are you a hundred percent sure that the
Rook is great on D1 I don't know if it
is or isn't it's it's certainly Theory
B5 and we would expect Bishop B3 to land
on the board it's a strange move order
VAR this Queen's Gambit accepted that
I'm seeing uh between mvl and Duda who's
benefiting
uh there are some games I can tell you
in this position I see about 20 plus
games in my database here and uh
evaluation is just equal here there was
a there's a game by kramnik he played
against cardiacin in this position so um
Bishop B3 is the the main move here I
mean that's the like everybody played
that movie now after Bishop E7 at some
point you can you're probably gonna have
to play the move d4 but you still have
options like maybe to delay that for a
couple of more moves maybe play A4 okay
to put some pressure the idea is if you
somehow Force this move uh B4 you also
have the option to play D3 here and try
to go Knight bd2 Knight C4 and maybe
play the move d4 at at the time that you
feel it's the best you know maybe even
just keep it there for a long time so
that's that's might be what he's trying
uh Duda is trying to do in this position
but of course after the move A4 you
don't have to play the move before the
typical move in this position is to play
Queen B6 and just simply protect the B5
Pawn and it's hard to see how white is
going to continue the development by
keeping the pawn on detour and if you
play a move like D3 here then it's just
it's very passive I don't really like it
because you're not really putting any
pressure blocking display Bishop B7 and
Castle here so objectively there is just
no Advantage here for white uh but it's
interesting to see what is Duda going to
do here he's been playing pretty fast
here so I think he might be still in his
prep we do have as you suggested
the move A2 A4
on the board trying to create a little
bit of a weakness now I used to play a
Queens game it accepted uh quite often
as black and I remember playing against
Tony miles where I made an attempt to
sacrifice uh the pawn on the on B5 Tony
of course didn't accept my gracious
offer a b a b uh Rook takes A1 Queen
takes A1 I don't think you want to get
your hand caught in this particular
cookie jar because Queen takes Bishop
takes F3 will will upset you it's
strange if the defile was oh if the pawn
was already on D4 and yes I was open
that would have never worked exactly but
with one on day two yeah it has more
ideas here exactly with the pawn on D2
and again we do have Knight V8 DC D7 and
I think what Tony did against me is he
he did something like takes takes and
Knight A3
although again my memory that is the
best way to play yes sir you're white
and to maybe try to have a small plus
because you're forcing the move B4 right
and Knight Will Go On uh C4 here exactly
and at least you have something you have
that's controller that's C4 Square
sometimes it's not much but at least you
have a good Square for the Knight and
then you can continue with the
development either either D4 or even D3
in this position very good let's see an
ailing world champion dingler in now
Anish giri has played a very quiet
tournament but it's not because he's not
been trying to win the games he's
definitely been trying to win the games
uh good play has resulted in six draws
now he looks across the board and he
says you may be world champion
but if you're having a bad tournament I
see potential for a win let's see uh
what a wounded the only E4 game we have
today only E4 game okay and it's
interesting testing the two nights when
you grew up as a kid
did you spend any time looking at the
fried liver no okay you know what it is
the right Knight to G5
D5 takes I Must Have Spent A hundred
hours
I was thrilled by this crazy line where
the King goes in the center or the board
and I tell you it's a lot of weekends a
lot of misspent weekends I want to tell
you went into the study of the fried
liver most kids learn E4 E5 as their
first opening right but I was taught
DeForest first move with white and then
with black against E4 I only pushed the
C Pawn okay so there you go fortunately
I missed out on them boy you sure did I
tell you I could tell tell you about a
warp childhood you know Bishop C4 uh
Knight F6 now today I mean
I this is a kind of a lesser move uh I
think Bishop C5 has just become so
popular and even I noticed that uh
they're even delaying Knight F6 in some
uh cases
I have no idea whether they're trying to
get into early F5 Bishop C5 D6 Queen E7
Bishop E6 I'm not sure but Knight F6
d2d3 Bishop C5 okay uh Bishop G5 I
always was I was told
uh I don't know if I necessarily
subscribed to this point of view I was
told that the move Bishop G5 is
premature when black hasn't castled
because if black plays the move G5 and
you drop back with the bishop then black
has weakened his King side if he's
castled that's supposed to be a bat and
no no but if you play G5 and you Castle
long maybe the move G5 is pretty good
but these guys do not make errors early
in the opening so Bishop G5
prepared by Ani c2c3
um stopping future Knight D4 is
preparing the c3d4 A7 A5 maybe it's a
very typical position except that and
played Bishop G5 exactly which is a
little bit off the beat track Knight D2
Bishop A7 A4 and that
my friends appears to be the novelty is
that right uh VAR a2a4 we're in new
territory I don't have any games in my
database
but the move A5 I wanted to mention
earlier black played out a little bit
more rare move in that position the main
move here is the move A6 I'll go a
couple of moves back here to show you
guys like this position has been played
many many times over 200 games in my
database and A6 is by far the most
popular move about 100 games played a
little bit more a compact move you know
controlling the B5 and then you can go
page seven gives you a little bit
more flexibility once you put the pawn
on A5 you don't have that any longer
because you the idea is you want to move
the bishop back but the main idea is you
want to control this B4 Square to
prevent that and but that leaves you
with some lights here so after Castle
not bd2 which pay Seven now A4 was
played and this is actually played in
order to avoid this move A4 completely
because at some point you can play let's
say you Castle there is an idea not not
necessarily in this position but you
have this and this Pawn cannot be
captured because of the discovery check
Bishop F2 so this is we saw a similar
idea in a game firuja versus Wesley so
so but in that position uh A4 is played
here and no games in my database here
and again Anish is playing very fast
he's got one hour and 33 minutes still
and ding is spending some time here so
definitely Anish is more comfortable I
think out of the opening well uh his
prep speaks for itself but it
and in there head to head
four to two in favor of Anish Gary yes
and I didn't realize they played each
other so many times 21 draws as well
they've also of course played lots of
rapid and Blitz but that's an impressive
classical score by Anish Gary
very very good uh if I can pick your
brain for just a second here VAR
um again uh boldly stating the obvious I
was told that that don't play Bishop G5
too early wait for the guy to Castle
first so it makes it more Awkward for
the second player to play the move G7 G5
uh obviously Anish disagrees with that
rule of thumb has it been a rule of
thumb for you
uh well I've I've been a D4 player all
my life right so I I actually never I
only played like a couple of E4 games in
my career so not as familiar with this
type of positions but uh I've heard that
before also that you want to wait for
casting because oftentimes in this
positions black can play the move G5 and
he's not afraid that you know his King
is going to be under attack later on so
perhaps we might see something like that
happening here dig is considering it
because if you Castle into this pin then
you're gonna have to worry about how am
I gonna unpin this pin because your
Bishop is all the way on A7 right it was
somewhere on C5 sometimes you play if
the pawn is only seven you play Bishop
B7 back I've seen that idea before so I
think ding is considering what to play
let me show you a couple of the key
moves here black can try to do here
Queen E7 is one alternative to try to
wait a little bit to see what is white
going to do and after you Castle this
move G5 is a possibility here you play
G5 attacking the bishop Bishop goes back
on GT and then you play the move Bishop
D7
just trying to complete your development
and again you're not sure yet where
you're going to cancel here whether
you're going to Castle long but you're
waiting to see what is white going to do
in this in this position
so but while I was showing you this ding
just made the move and he canceled
wow he castled into the pin and here H3
H3 is a possibility here for white is
one option but again white can play uh
many different moves here
back to you guys yeah well uh sorry bar
I'm just going to stay with you again
and pick your brain because I'm thinking
about that pin and help me out here uh
there's no way
to break the pin other than playing the
move G7 G5
and uh
that comes with some very serious
consequences especially as I haven't
castled with white uh let me just bring
that game of dingler in up on my board
for just a second so again uh if you
don't play G7 G5 this pin you know just
stays there the whole time now I saw
that the engine like the move H3 I don't
know if that's a Prelude
to G4 or not pointing Bishop G4 yeah
um okay after H3 uh you have a few
different ways you can play one option
is to play Bishop E6 Bishop E6 yes okay
and the pin is still there but you don't
have to worry about it right away uh
there is no like immediate uh danger at
the moment at least and one idea after
HD is this move yes sir Knight goes on
H2 with a direct idea to jump in on G4
and uh oh this is very interesting how
black tries to solve the problem of this
pin actually Knight B8 is a playable
move you're gonna waste couple of
tempies but you're gonna try to bring
the Knight on D7 so Knight G4 and you go
Knight bd7 here
and uh and this looks okay for black
queen E2 for example you play Queen E7
I don't know Nancy do you get the
feeling that this is modern chess this
is a different type of chest than what
you studying uncomfortable for black I
know right that that pin but okay uh it
still exists but Knight B8 and Knight D7
well we'll definitely keep uh our eye on
uh this intriguing game as it unfolds I
wanted to go to Wesley so versus Fabi
because again two extraordinarily a
well-prepared opening uh theoreticians
and you saw in their head to head just
how close they are uh at the very very
top there okay when we left it we left
it here Bishop C6 uh very well known
attempt at neutralizing this long
diagonal from Black's perspective please
don't do anything please don't move let
me play the move Knight D7 let me play
the move Bishop D5 which will come with
a gain of tempo and then the moment
moment I play C5 I've equalized that's
it that's what's on Black's Edition and
white naturally wants to prevent black
from successfully playing the move C7 C5
Bishop G5 developing at Knight C3 H6
takes takes well that makes it that much
harder to play C5 now that the Knight is
like retok on F6 with a bishop then
white can play E4
right and then you start to kind of get
a little bit worried that this bishop
might be in some Danger
so that's why
it does allow Knight E5
which I think came later yes immediately
uh Bishop takes G2 King takes G2 uh
Bishop B4 I see from my database that
the players are still in uh Theory and
uh how does engine uh evaluate the
position again this is their life and
you just see this extraordinarily close
score five wins four losses 29 that's a
lot of draws Wow have you ever played
anyone this many times no no I think the
the player I played the most was like
Victor corcinoid like something like 25
or Beyond Tima something like 25. we
just didn't play as frequently uh as the
guys of today play against each other
and I know at one time we were all like
unbelievably stunned by Kasparov and
carpa because they played a hundred
games and more with one another five
World Championship matches with one
another and they played I think about
130 games actually and the scores were
incredibly incredibly close but nobody
else was even close to those two guys I
don't think anyone's ever going to break
the record exactly something like a
Perpetual opponent but uh but again uh
you saw just there how frequently uh the
players do play VAR jump in and tell us
about the current position how do the
engines evaluate what has happened thus
far and the position I mean at the
moment it's just a very very slight
Advantage for white the last move played
by Fabiano might be a little bit of a
surprise for Wesley because the main
move in that position is the move C6
instead of the movie should be for
Bishop B4 still played there are a
couple of games in the database but let
me show you some of the the
possibilities after the move C6 right so
because that's more like a main move and
very natural move just very solid to
control this D5 break to make sure white
can never play the move D5 and again
this was played by Lanier Dominguez
Superstar from India go cash and uh very
it's it's very solid structure here
white usually plays E3 then you can play
the move Queen B6 and very hard to break
through because you know black doesn't
have any weaknesses so I I like this
position for black but Fabiana played
the move Bishop before and here we see
the first thing for Wesley here he's
trying to figure out what to play here
so if you try uh let's see if you can
play this move D5 for example because it
looks like it's a logical move to do to
open up the D file if you but but the
black has few options here you can
actually take on C3 and this will lead
to a queen sacrifice D takes E6
Bishop takes E5
Rook takes d8 and now you have to
capture with the F Rook because if you
capture with this Rook You're Gonna Lose
The Rook after the move E7 so you have
to be careful so you take with Rook F to
d8 now it takes F7 check King f8 and
very important that Queen C5 is not
winning the bishop because you have the
more Bishop D6 so at this point
evaluation is all zeros but lots of
Dynamics I can see here and eventually I
think black will pick up this F7 Pawn
but overall it's Dynamic equality here
another option here is after the move D5
you also can play this move Queen D6
very concrete attacking the Knight only
five and white needs to retreat with
this Knight to F3 and then you can try
to equalize the game with the move Queen
A6 and after the capture you can take
with the rook and this looks okay for
black the bishop is very strong on B4
exactly it's interesting that you got
that material imbalance of a queen for
Rook bishop and Knight the very same
material imbalance that Wesley had
against dingler in and the computer
liked the pieces in that particular game
in this particular position black hat
pardon me white has this Pawn on it
seven rather large majority on the king
side and in the center but no c7c6 VAR
instead Bishop B4 on the board is their
um
well it's kind of funny I'm looking at
this the the Knight on the E5 is pretty
yes
doesn't really attack anything unless I
am like VAR saying uh playing some
tactical uh slugfest with Knight F7 or
Knight G6 I'm not that sure the knight's
that great so I would kind of be
attracted myself to the move Knight D3 I
guess I have to take
wonder I mean make a judgment call
is white better in this particular
ending
excuse me Queen takes Check Yes exactly
Queen takes well I can probably take
with either but let's take a look at
Knight takes D5 okay that's a Tempo sure
I guess
prepping E4 prepping C4 I kind of I'd be
happy if you put your knight on B6 if
you did play Knight to B6 then you're
inviting me to play Knight C5 which is
kind of nice because I get to defend the
A4 Pawn while also tickling uh the pawn
on B7 I'm I'm just going to make an
assumption that I'm slightly better with
white but the move Bishop B4 when Bobby
plays his openings he does a lot of this
stuff for very concrete reasons
um Bishop B4 are you are you trying to
capture the Knight on C3 what's the
what's the deeper idea behind Bishop B4
bar I think after 1992 that's actually
one of the top moves for right here I
think he will play the move Bishop E7
because that line that you were showing
Gasser yeah after Bishop C3 let me show
you here so btx C3 Queen D5
um
Queen takes D5 if you take with the
Knight guys after C4 white has a pretty
nice uh advantage in the end game
because uh you cannot uh play Knight
before I can just capture oops and then
you're losing the yeah the before pass
so that doesn't work and if you have to
retreat after C4 then I have a complete
control of the center so this is a very
pleasant advantage and if you take with
the pawn I think this is a very
important idea in order to obtain an
advantage you need to try to play this
move C4 here so in particular I like
this move first you can also play 95 and
try to play for the quick C4 here in
this position then you can use the B
file later on so let's say if you play
C6
you can just play C4 and after
exchanging you will have pressure on
this B7 Pawn here so this is a slightly
better position for white here space
that's why after 93 I think uh I expect
to see Fabi play the move Bishop E7 and
uh yeah sometimes you can even get this
Pawn to E4 here but then I played C6 and
then you have to worry about when you
put the pawn on four you have to worry
about this Pawn hanging and also in some
positions D4 Pawn will be hanging let's
say when I play the move Queen B6 rook
fd8 in the meantime black once again
it's got this super solid position that
is going to be very hard to break
through all right thank you for that bar
and as always we've really enjoyed your
uh comments uh join the discussion stump
uh panel of experts with your questions
how do people get in touch with this
message you can send us tweets using
hashtag super bad chess classic or you
can tag granchester and you can also use
YouTube and twitch to send us your
comments and questions on St Louis chess
club Channel and let's send it over to
Bucharest
thanks yazia I just want to give you
guys a rundown of a couple of games that
I'm having my eyes on and what's
happening in the playing Hall and I'm
going to start with this game between
Ali Reza and Jan at the beginning of the
show I said that Jan is a definitely
been besting alibraza in their head to
head in general four to one as of right
now and even last year with the black
pieces in the super batches classic I
believe that was a scotch if I remember
it correctly alireza essay the the
scotch unfortunately backfired and lost
that game but right now he's taking a
completely different approach and uh
he's shying away from any sort of
theoretical discussion he started off
with D4 Knight F6 Knight F3 D5 and now
E3 he's more or less taking a page from
ding Lee rand's book from the world
championship match when he played the
London just very innocuous stuff in the
opening trying to get Nepal out of the
opening he's not expecting to get an
advantage but he's he's expecting to get
a fresh position
um one that perhaps Nepal did not uh
deeply analyzed at home and this is
exactly what he got in this game check
it out E3 C5 bhp2 Knight C6 and now we
have this move a bishop to G4 and this
is something a tendency uh that I've
spotted from nepo he's trying to play
very concrete lines even against this
type of e3d for kg solutions for white
so unfortunately sometimes this type of
concrete lines can backfire putting the
bishop on H5 perhaps not the best placed
piece and now we see this position a
bishop to B2 Rook to d8 this is the last
move we have but I'm looking at the game
right now what if I just simply go C4
just the typical way to try to open up
the center C4 attack the phone on D5 if
you go Castle sure you can do that but
now I have options right I can take on
D5 I can also play B5 I can push my
pawns on the queen side and make life
harder for your pieces I'm seeing a
slight Advantage for white and my Bishop
on B2 that monster on the long diagonal
is just doesn't have a counterpart the
bishop on D6 it's not very well placed
sure it's looking towards H2 but what
are you attacking on H2 how are you
going to create that very dangerous
battery on the b8h2 diagonal you're not
going to be able to do that as black so
your pieces are just not in their
optimal Spots I'm looking at the
position and I'm seeing
um a slight Edge for alireza and
definitely a practical Edge for alireza
and I have to say I like what I'm saying
from him out of the opening let's take a
look at what's happening in this game
the game that we were discussing between
Richie report and Bogdan Daniel at the
act the battle of the Romanians in this
one and we are remember it started off
with some tension uh after the first
move was made Bogdan was pointing to the
Deep part and saying hey move the pawn
back move upon back uh you're not
allowed to start the game with a move
played by somebody else quite a funnier
currency it's probably for the first
time that I'm seeing this
um but things have calmed down and this
is what we have right now
we have the trumpovsky there is this
Knight on E1 I really like what Richie
has been doing for the last few moves we
see uh this move C3 Knight to D2 Knight
to F3 and Knight to E1 you're wondering
where is that Knight going you've been
moving with that Knight quite a few
times well it's headed towards D3 that
is the optimal Square in the position
and this is probably what I'm expecting
uh to see from these players uh Bogdan
played King to h8 make use of the fact
that your G7 Pawn is on F5 the GE file
is open you might as well try to take
advantage of that create some chances
create some counter play at the same
time where is the counter play on the G
file sure you can do that Knight to D3
Rook to G8 but then I just simply go G3
how do you attack me how do you continue
the attack this is an interesting dance
between the pieces and between the
structure white would love to play the
move F4 and uh just kill the bishop on
hsis blows it up the problem is take
full advantage of the fact that you have
so much control over that E5 Square as
white the problem is that once you play
the move F4 so let's just make some
random moves let's say queen to E7 and
now you play F4 you're giving up one
critical Square in the position and that
is the square E4 and unfortunately you
cannot afford to do that because I'm
just simply going to jump with the
Knight immediately Knight to F6 Knight
to E4 and that Knight on e4 is going to
be Untouchable you don't want to
exchange that because after that the
pawn on e4 would be deadly and also that
Knight on e4 is looking towards both
sides of the board maybe I can launch a
minority attack B5 A5 B4 or maybe I can
sacrifice that Knight at some point on
G3 and try to get to your king so you
cannot allow to do that
as white you have to keep the pawn on F2
if you keep the pawn on F2 then where is
your plan and this is what I'm trying to
understand in the position I think this
is a very cagey position and white is
going to take it slow it's going to play
G3 let's say uh Knight to F for the
other Knight to F or knight from E to to
F4 keep the Knight on D3 that's the best
place you have uh that's the best piece
you have in the position put some pieces
on the E file Queen to E2 Rook to E1 and
then try at some point to exchange a
pair of knights and leave one of your
Knights against the bishop on H6 which
doesn't have any Targets in the position
I think this is the strategical plan B
uh for a white and I think it gives him
a slight Edge though still a very tense
game between these two Romanian players
thank you Christian sorry I was just so
anxious to turn your attention to the
game between Anish Gary and ding Loren
because we've been and talking about
this pin this pin of the bishop on H4
uh
of the night on F6 and the Queen on d8
and as black I was always told don't do
this don't allow this don't don't a
castle because one day you're going to
play G5 now we saw that well actually 98
and maybe Knight D7 is a way potentially
for ding Loren to solve this rather
annoying let's face it pin instead he
played the move G5 now I was always told
that these sacrifices it's a piece for
two pawns are actually really really
really dangerous when I'm not castled
that is to say when my Kings not on the
king side normally
black and sometimes sorry King G7
normally black sometimes he gets to play
Rook h8 and Rook H4 and somehow he deals
with this pin but in such a case I could
play 8 4 and the fact that I haven't
castled means that you're not solving
the problem the the problem Bishop on
Bishop on G5 Queen F3 and okay it's not
overwhelming attack instantly obviously
I still need to play the move F2 F4 to
get more pressure white actually has
another idea because they haven't
castled yet yes white can very quickly
bring the night overnight F1 Knight G3
going to H5
well Knight F1 Knight G3 uh seriously
right I mean if you the the the whole
question from White's point of view is
how he can how can he put more pressure
on the F6 Knight and you're absolutely
right now see when you put your knight
on G3 you instantly realize Bishop takes
F6 is Lights Out it's over and you know
VAR I'm looking at this position I'm
just saying there's a ding layer in is
in trouble he's in trouble again sorry
let me put it that way absolutely yeah
sir I think this G5 move uh he probably
mixed up something because now he's
thinking and he needs to find some
really only moves but still evaluation
is an unicious favor here I think he's
in big big trouble here there's lots of
danger here I will show you some of the
best moves now for both sides here and
so we can see how they can get uh there
so in this position here after Queen F3
you you can start with the Rook h8 or
Bishop E6 it's going to lead to the same
thing so let's say Bishop B6 uh snazzy
mentioned this Knight F1 is the key move
in this position nice and now a rook
goes on
h8 yeah to stop Knight H25 yeah here you
can play Knight G3 uh but in this Knight
H5 idea he's always going to have a rook
H5 there and he will be happy to let's
say if you take on F6 Queen H5 so main
idea Knight F1 you actually want to
bring it to E3 now because this will
give you some options of with Knight D5
or Knight G4 later on so Bishop takes C4
is one option here
and now there is this move Knight G4
oh and now you're threatening Bishop F6
here and the only move and not to lose
the game immediately is this move Bishop
takes F2 wow
because if you take with the King there
is some 94 Queen G5 ideas so you have to
play Knight takes if you take with the
queen you're gonna allow the move Knight
G4 now black will be actually winning
so but after Knight takes F2
you have to bring the bishop back to E6
why can't simply castle and again this
pin is still remaining very very strong
pin and often times to get rid of this
pin black plays the move key G6 to try
to put the pressure on the bishop here
and only move for white is
H4 to protect the bishop and now
Rook H5 with the idea to capture this
bishop on G5
but white still has a very strong attack
here Queen G3 is one option
to continue the pressure here and now
the King on G6 is also also vulnerable
some very sharp lines here uh it's not
going to be easy to navigate for both
sides but at the end white is white is
in the driver's seats here
wow very very nice
uh as well three rounds of the Sprint to
the Finish there's not much uh many
games to get back into the contest it's
punish her to win this he would quickly
jumped and join the literally that would
be hitting the trampoline for sure as he
would move to plus one and England the
woes of dingler in uh would really be
continuing in that line you were showing
though VAR uh you know just dropping the
F2 pawn and obviously it's still a nice
initiative I'm looking at this position
and I'm saying you know what
what would be really just a lot of fun
it's just to do nothing just to slowly
slowly like if I'm white I would find
myself attracted to playing moves like
castles
age four
Rook F1 Queen G3 and just say look what
is your Bishop doing this is your well I
don't know uh what is your extra piece
your extra piece is the Knight on C6
what exactly is it doing well it's not
bothering me slowly slowly I'm going to
start thinking how do I get in the move
when I'm castled long how do I get in
the moves D4 how do I get in the moves
F4 how are you going to deal with Queen
G3 and yeah it's all on you White's
position looks so good that it feels
like white doesn't need to rush to get
the material back or Checkmate it's just
keep improving keep attacking and black
should collapse as a Defender that's
just terrible when you're sitting there
you know because you you you're seeing
the ghost you're seeing the threats and
it's sort of like and your opponent's
not ignoring you he's your opponent's
going castles and Rook F1 is making all
these Preparatory moves I really think
that Ding is under a lot of pressure
right now are clocks a factor I've been
we were told Anish was playing yes
instantly only spent two minutes so far
right and I think is already has spent
more than 30 minutes
30. there is one idea guys I want to
point out it's uh that it may look it's
not it looks like white can do
um uh a lot of different things yeah but
there are some ways that black can try
to untangle here so I'll show you if you
play quietly here please so for example
in this position if after Bishop E6
let's say you play long Castle right one
idea that he can try to do is to capture
on C4 okay let's say you take back with
a knight right and then he plays this
McQueen E7 with the idea to go Queen E6
okay and that way now there's no longer
going to be a pin on that uh on the
queen here and then he can move the
Knight like for example here already
black is already better here so uh it
you have to really play this Knight F1
Knight E3 idea pretty quickly because
once the queen is there then you're
already free to move the Knight on H7
then you you only have two pawns for a
piece which is not going to be that much
once I uh untangle from this pin here so
for example you can continue H4 Queen E6
so so I can't and have my cake and eat
it too I can't just enjoy my position
slowly because you do have a way of
unwinding VAR exactly yes yeah Queen E7
Bishop E6 the other I I don't know if
it's just me but the other thing that
comes to my mind is when I look at this
position with the queen on F3 the King
on G7 and I say you know if I could
teleport Harry the H bond to H6 that
would be really really really good right
like if I so I'm going to make a very
bad move for for for black just if I
could just uh
you know your King on G7
is uh defending the Knight on F6 and uh
ideas that were you you're forced to you
know step up and you know put your your
head in a noose essentially as uh I'm
I'm sitting there saying uh I don't know
is H4 H5 another attacking ideas or is
it all about Knight F1 no absolutely you
can play if if black plays a quiet mode
like that Bishop B6 but he already
played Bishop E6 actually he did play
before he tried to trade that but h4h5
is an idea that you you have to look for
it all the time so Bishop E6 play the
boy thing and here actually
um Anish really needs to find this move
Knight F1 it's a very very important
move here I think he will play it to
bring this Knight to E3 uh this is this
is very important to have a knight only
three to have all these options to go to
D5 F5 G4 so evaluation is actually a
little bit dropping it was showing more
and now as you can see on the screen
it's dropped a little bit
you really need to run this position on
a very strong and a very strong computer
to know the exact evaluation now you see
it's jumping up again here again it's
it's an advantage for white but a lot of
complicated lines ahead that players
have to navigate
explaining for for a second to our
audience because you said the engine
evaluations jumping up and down and
explain to our audience why that happens
why doesn't the computer just stop at a
moment you've got 1.2 there as you can
see here we have the evaluation here we
have the depth the depth is very
important deeper it is it's more likely
it's got the most accurate evaluation
here so see okay it's on 23 out of 26
right now so the stronger machines will
get to this depth much faster and will
give you the the 100 evaluation here
that's why we see some fluctuation here
and that's why it was 0.7 0.9 1.2 so
again on a very powerful machine if you
put this and let it run for one or two
minutes you you might get a different
different evaluation here so I'm told on
a more powerful machine that our
colleague Darius has on it's about plus
two right now they have always two yes
okay so wow and by the way Knight F1 or
did Knight F1 get not yet not yet Anish
is thinking right now and it may have
played it act no he did not I apologize
yeah so Knight F1 is the key move
absolutely yes Knight F1 with idea to
bring the Knight only three again you
have a rook h8 here you also have King
H6 can you just we didn't look at King
G6 I think King G6 now your move Yasser
needs to be played okay absolutely only
move H4 to have an advantage and here we
see an attempt to try to protect F6 this
idea we saw in a another variation much
more calm situation than this we had
that he could have tried to protect the
pin but now
H3 look at this move okay that's a
visual yeah now that's not an easy
movement now you're fighting Rook G3
yeah and if you take this is just
completely winning after Pawn takes now
on top of the the pin you also have huge
problems on your light squares here so
Knight bd7 and now he can simply
increase the pressure by Knight H2
Knight G4 unit five and you're just on a
rook here but the block is just
completely completely busted in this
position well he's so tied up this you
know personally I just hate being in
pins I mean I just have this feeling of
physical helplessness that I just
despise so Grand Masters hate to be in
pins and world champions no exception
but
looks like she's deliberately trying to
calm himself down because he must be so
excited oh very very much so I guess
this amazing chance to defeat the world
champion well I have to say if you think
about his preparation for a moment and
the fact that he had like one hour and
33 minutes after say it doesn't moves
and he's playing all of these moves
without Castle
so he's thinking maybe I can catch
a very big fish I can catch a very big
fish by by delay castles and I can play
Knight takes G5
imagine
my opponent falls into my net
well is it a real trap so I have to
believe that Anish is very familiar with
this exact position and that Knight F1
has been on this a home computer
yeah even if it wasn't exactly in this
position he has seen very similar
positions with Knight F1 exactly exactly
and he works very very very hard his
chessable courses are lauded for uh
their uh precision
and he works he works really really hard
in in his opening so Knight F1 we'll
keep an eye on this one but it sure is
looking good alireza farugia versus nepo
big big big key match
c2c4 takes
you don't want to recapture with the
Knight I think
I must have fallen for some
people's like this like 20 times in my
career not just once not just twice not
just Thrice but you don't want to fall
for that so you want to get out of uh
that uh
pin
so that you can play on your next turn
Knight takes C4 or I'm tempted with
black to just throw the pawn with C3 yes
just since you can't keep it you're not
going to be able to keep it you might as
well be irritating yeah exactly because
Bishop
right you can later make a Tempo but
please but you
yeah so I think black should start with
C3 and then just Castle okay but white
does look like they have a pleasant
Advantage yeah and for me I mean I would
be the one asking you a Salient question
I would be the one saying okay if I
drive your night away maybe maybe yeah
so back here I I understand what you
mean about C4 C3 in the sense that you
can misplace my piece a little bit I'm
not sure if I should be playing Bishop
F3 or not the one move that I probably
be tempted to play is simply to stop you
maybe five yes that was the question
would you still play B5 because I really
don't want to allow black to play B5
true I'm not sure A6 Bond but yeah yeah
I get you takes
uh
it just feels like the two Bishops one
day the moment you win back the spawn on
C4
feels like uh White should be the one
pushing the action Wesley so versus Fabi
when we left it we we saw probably
playing the move uh Bishop B4 and Wesley
didn't play Knight D3 or anything like
that he said you know what D2 E3 is one
of those yeah and it's a useful Tempo uh
in some sometimes I can
uh reroute the Queen the queen may not
be ideal on C4 but on F3 protects my
king and maybe patrols the diagonal E3
C7 C6 a move that version was pointing
out that is very common Queen C4 now
93 and queen takes B7 maybe on White's
agenda black defends the B7 Pawn
and I think we're caught up to the
players looks very very solid to me VAR
I don't see white as having much of
anything actually
absolutely yes sir yeah black is very
very solid I wouldn't be completely
surprised if we see some type of
repetition soon Knight C3 Bishop before
Knight A2 it's really hard to see how
Wesley can really crack this position
black has no weaknesses here and
evaluation is also all zeros here at the
moment let's just look at couple of
options here for Wesley if he's trying
to play for a win if you play the move
on Knight C3 this is going to be met
most likely by the move Bishop before
Bishop is very annoying here black
hitting the B file and also very strong
here so in order to remove this bishop
you really need this move Knight A2
let's say you don't want to repeat you
want to play the move Rook ac1 just just
to continue playing here and here's
black has a few options here even a move
like B5 is a possibility now because of
the tactic we have if you take on B5
Pawn takes B5 and you cannot take the
pawn because your king is on a bad
Square here and there is a move Queen B7
check and picking up the Knight on B
five sure so there are some ideas like
this that he needs to also consider the
movie five again not not not necessary
to play this move you can also just uh
play Queen C7 and sit on the position
but it's an interesting alternative to
play B5 most likely white will have to
play 95 here put pressure on C6 but
after you play this move B5 this is an
excellent Square for your queen to go to
now you're threatening to play the C5
essentially forcing uh White to go back
to G1 here and uh the game the game
continues here from here on uh there are
of course also some risk when you play a
move like B5 because you created some
weakness here as well but black has
Bishop D6 now try to eliminate the
Knight
and if you take on B5
Bishop takes E5 Pawn takes and you can
play Knight D7 here putting pressure on
E5 and you're pinned actually that's why
you cannot really take on C6 here so
this is kind of complicated but it looks
like a black is fine here in this
position as well Rook ac1 has just been
played by Wesley and uh here Fabiano
needs to decide what to do here he has a
couple of options here E5 is a
possibility here as well which is a
typical idea you look for C5 and look
for B5 after A4 A5 A4 inclusion
sometimes you don't want to play C5
because of B5 square is really weak but
this E5 is absolutely fine move and a
good idea to try to completely equalize
the game thank you VAR and as we uh
prepare for our first break that means
that we should check in to our good
friends at Q Boutique and see what
specials they may have for you today
let's take a look-see
what do we have we have presented the
newest edition of this St Louis chess
club Polo
and it is not to be missed polos are 100
polyester and feature an outstanding
durable rubberized logo of the St Louis
chess club on the front available in
men's and women's Styles and in seven
In Color Wow do all your shopping at Q
Boutique stl.com and make us proud we'll
see you on the other side of the break
[Music]
in Forest Park the muni's premier season
bursting with comedies romance and Magic
Begins June 12th with the muni premiere
of beautiful the Carole King musical
the Epic summer continues with Disney's
Beauty and the Beast chess West Side
Story Little Shop of Horrors rent and
sister
[Music]
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85 000 students in both in
school and after school programs we
created the select chess training
program in the junior select chess
training program in order to elevate the
skill level in students across the St
Louis area these students receive
professional training from Grand Master
varusha nicobian other programs include
chess cops a partnership with the St
Louis Police Department looking to
improve relationships between at-risk
kids and police officers in the St Louis
area with over 600 students playing
chess over the board since 2019. the St
Louis chess club has also created a
chess merit badge for the scouts BSA
quickly becoming one of the most popular
badges with more than 200 thousand
Scouts earning the badge since 2011.
students of chess can also pick up a
copy of read and write chess thanks to
Club co-founder Dr Jeannie Karen
sinkfield anyone can learn how to
understand chess notation in no time we
view chess as a valuable educational
tool learn more about our Scholastic
programming by visiting
stlouischessclub.org education
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back these
are our standings after six rounds of
playing Nasi Duart do the honors please
all right we have fabriano caruana
leading the tournament with four points
and then closely following fieruja so
and Rockford just half the point behind
the chasing pack an honest Geary on the
outside looking in he's got the chances
as MBL also on 50 but for us I mean
we're just looking at dinglerant's
struggles
we can all empathize I mean he just won
the World Championship doubtlessly he's
exhausted as is nepo on the other hand a
lot of us including myself we were
optimistic that both those players
championed and Challenger would be
coming into this tournament full of
women Vigor anxious to prove that all of
their preparation was not for naught and
to you know excite the chess fans of the
world dingler in I've never understood
the physical component in that place in
chess exactly if you're physically tired
it affects your mental state as well
absolutely well
as we see our weekend crowd in Bucharest
now keep in mind that this is the yeah
Full House this is the playing Hall but
keep in mind that there are other
activities that are going there's a
media center there there will be a
commentary room there'll be VIP rooms so
this is just all within the Grand Hotel
Bucharest and the playing Hall looks to
be a little bit packed I was kind of
impressed what Christian said that his
father Yes got uh
Richard Rapport was a little bit annoyed
and started rapping with his father and
then and then Christian said well my
father's an Arbiter I go okay it's a
family of Chess flares there uh but uh
let's just jump into the dingler in
position for a moment because it's
Bishop E6 and much to my great surprise
Anish Gary has taken his time to play
what we think is is an absolutely
crucial move that fits into everything
that white is going to be trying to do
and it's a little bit hidden it's not
intuitively obvious that you want to
play this move Knight F1 but uh Nasi you
pointed out I want to play it but you're
not sure if you should do it right away
and what move order should I play
castles is that important but as you
were pointing out and I see once you've
put the Knight on F1 and once you put
the Knight on G3 or E3 or E3 you've got
Bishop takes F6 check and Knight H5
check ideas or just again as he was
about to say Knight to E3 you don't
really want to capture this at night and
allow F tags and suddenly the open
f-file so this Knight
the key move is that the Knight on D2
does nothing yes bring it into the
attack Knight F1 that's what it's all
about Fabi by the way who leads the
competition is playing his closed
captioning not available
just offered their reputation or Wesley
I guess with move Knight C3 right I mean
H5 Knight C3 Bishop B4 sorry Wesley
plays Knight A2 then we'll see the
bishop drop back to D6
um I think this is a case not so much
that Wesley has a fantastic position and
he should be playing on but this is a
case that Wesley was shaken
uh by his error in judgment uh yesterday
uh he he agreed he acquiesced to a rep a
repetition in a position where he was
material advantage but he thought the
game was balanced whereas the engines
were going no no no no no you have a
huge uh plus two Advantage even if we
ignore yesterday's result yes he just
didn't get any advantage in the opening
today that is true and uh he he can
definitely play on but position is very
equal yes uh I I I don't dispute that at
all alireza versus nepo alireza he had
abrasive wins back-to-back wins after
starting with a loss then he went up
against Favi and it was again one of
these uh number number one in the
tournament and versus number two uh
could Perugia continue a streak not at
all in fact Fabby had uh Ali Reza up
against the wall and let him go now uh
today
the question is uh can Ali raise a
snapback as he again you play against
nepo and you think to yourself
is an excellent result against nepo but
if you look at the cross table you see
that nepo's doing very badly he's not uh
he's not his himself just like I think
yeah so let's catch up with the play uh
C3 uh your move uh uh from your lips to
nepo's ears Bishop takes C3 castles now
here I was getting myself all excited
about the prospects of playing for B5
Queen takes A7 while we were on break we
were looking at some lines and okay
there were reasons
why maybe capturing the pond was an
ideal Knight C4 was Ali Reza's move 94
attacking the bishop on C3 Bishop
dropped back and that was one of the
reasons why you wanted to play C4 C3 was
that Tempo is always on tap and uh well
again why does eyeballing an opportunity
to play for B5 I'm just realizing now
when we're discussing B5 earlier we only
looked at Knight B8 but there was a
knight E5 option as well there was a
knight E5 option okay because uh thank
you right there is a pin
so maybe that's why feroza played Knight
C4 first so Queen takes
hey it's what I do for a living I mean
you know
just just trying to uh
fill up my house with Furniture uh I
want to play Bishop C5 and 95 at the
same time right you get your choice
you don't get to do both but Bishop C5
and Knight D5 at the same time
well 95 unfortunately probably just lets
me off the hook a bit be sure I'm going
to start with Bishop C5 and I'll
probably uh
take a step back again you don't have
Rook text each I have Pro K-8 I forgot
about okay yet at what moment right here
Rook A8 Rook A8 you you you force my
queen in this case into the center of
the board with the move Queen D4
intriguing I'm I'm not 100 sure uh Ali
Reza played Knight C4 looks okay Bishop
C2 Bishop Bishop B2 now there is this
move Knight G5 could that be an annoying
move actually let me jump in here guys
uh Knight C4 was uh inaccuracy and
inaccuracy yes in fact now black is
actually absolutely fine here right so
in this position he uh I will show you
the key moment here instead of the move
Knight C4 he had to play this movie Rook
fd1 which actually actually makes a lot
of sense you want to bring the Rook into
the game and this other Rook to see fun
and only after that you want to be able
to play moves like Knight C4 perhaps put
the bishop on B2 first and here actually
white has a pretty nice Advantage here
it's like a half upon Advantage here
because this Rook is actually misplaced
here in order to bring this Rook into
the game you have to waste another Tempo
to play Rook C8 and then to play Rook
fd1 here would have been a nice edge
here for white here but the move Knight
C4 the problem is exactly what you you
mentioned the answer this move Knight G5
here and you cannot take on G5 because
it who is hanging right so you can take
on D6 here
but then Rook takes D6 not even Bishop
F3 but Rook takes D6 right away yeah
right away and again you're threatening
to take on F3 and if let's say you play
the move B5
then actually Knight takes F3 is one
option you can also Play Bishop F3 but I
get worried if I was white yeah now the
the pawn structure is ruined and you
have the move Queen G5 check
yeah I know I'm getting worried here for
if you play King H1
there is even the move Knight E5 now
comes in right yeah Queen F5 a lot of a
lot of pressure here uh perhaps after
this move you have to play
Queen G4 and now if take actually I I
like this end game I think white is a
little bit better but
by the way uh sorry to disturb you there
VAR but uh the game between Wesley and
Fabi the players are repeating repeating
and we do expect a draw to be agreed
soon uh please continue and there you
have it
let's stay on this just so we can see
the them making the draw
um the handshake
now there's the Hardy hand clasp
done deal great great result for Fabi
because USD was one of the players who
was chasing him so easy draw with the
black pieces pieces is good good result
for him definitely no question about it
especially in the head-to-head uh five
wins for Wesley four losses for Wesley
but 29 draws I mean now 30 drops and now
30. let's make it an even 30 back over
to you just one more cute moment here in
this position after Queen G5 check Queen
G4 it looks like white is a little bit
better but there is this clever move
Knight E5 nice and if you take Bishop E5
Queen takes C5 and uh is you know block
might be even a little bit better here
if you play Queen G5 here actually
you're going to be down a Pawn on this
end game so again a small detail here
but this move Knight C4 actually
inaccuracy and looks like now if Yan
finds this move Knight G5 he has been
spending a lot of time actually probably
one of the only games in this tournament
where he's behind on the clock 15
minutes he is definitely considering
this move Knight G5 another option he
can try to do is this move Bishop B8
because this will give some options with
the move Queen C7 to create some
attacking options it's possible he's
considering to play this move as well
that's an attractive move I must say
Bishop B8 to to make that battery of
Queen z7 yeah and white can play Rook 81
Queen takes D1 and here you have uh you
can capture actually uh if you capture
with the Rook there is there is an
interesting tactic here Bishop takes F3
a little bit unusual that's why I want
to point out you have this move Knight
F2
C4 Knight and C4 Knight is unprotected
so if you take back now there is a queen
H4 check
King G1 Queen takes C4 picking up the
pawn but even even here I think it looks
looks like white uh can probably bail
out after the move Bishop C6
uh you don't really want to allow this
but it looks like you will be okay here
and maybe patient before because the
queen side pawns are really weak here
but again this is something you don't
want to allow here so again Jan is
thinking taking a long think here he has
two good options here Knight G5 which I
think is very natural he probably will
play that or the move Bishop B8 if he
wants to keep the pieces on the board
thank you thank you for that uh VAR I
have a question for you Nancy yes
imagine you have Napa's position you
kind of like nepo's position as black
you feel pretty comfortable and you have
two great options Bishop B8 because you
got this queen C7 battery and Away you
go and you got Knight G5 oops I should
bring up that uh so two great options
Bishop B8
with the idea of Queen C7 or Knight G5
exploiting this pin
how do you come to these termination of
which one do you make do you do a flip
of a coin no you calculate what do you
do how how do you break it situations
like this uh players will go with their
gut yeah so both are definitely good
options so it's personal preference
right that's exactly it yes for me
keeping the queens and as many pieces on
the board possible is a better option
you like I like more pieces on the board
okay so Bishop B8 would be my choice it
would be your choice just because as a
player you're happy to be the one with
the initiative happy to be the one with
attack a board full of pieces I'm more
of an in-game player I like simplified
positions where I'm better very
important and so I might find myself
attracted to Knight G5 I would I mean
Bishop B8 is one of those moves where
you know I really like the move but I
might convince myself that The Rook will
who knows that yeah maybe I even if I
pay a visit on H2 I may not come back
with a big reward so I I would find
myself drawn to Knight G5 I want to turn
our attention to dingler in because it
took him a lot longer than we thought 26
minutes that's a long thing but Anish
Gary did find the right move Knight F1
and VAR Jump Right In how is our world
champion going to survive what looks
like a very unpleasant attack absolutely
yeah very unpleasant he has to play a
lot of accurate moves here but Anish did
find this move Knight F1 after a long
thing here let's see what are the the
best options here for doing in this
position here so he can play the move
King G6 this is another idea in this
position he can try to attack the bishop
and you you have to play the move H4
here to protect
your bishop and here
this idea Rook H4 Rook H3 Rook G3 is
also coming through it's very strong so
you need uh the move Knight B8 I want to
show you some lines it's it's not easy
to play the move Knight B8 so let's say
if you play another move Rook G8 try to
bring the Rook into the game now Knight
E3
Knight is coming in bringing the 19
Bishop takes and always when they take
the Knight here you always just take
back with the pawn here because now you
have the f file to work with here as
well so
Bishop G4 is one option attacking a
queen now you actually can actually win
the peace back with Bishop F6 but even
better here is not to do that just to
play the move Queen G3 the pin is still
strong it's still remaining out there
and after Queen D7 only then you play
Bishop takes F6 King takes F6 and now
very cool move here I like this Castle
's with check yeah Castle we check now
the king is super safe and Rook F7 is
coming up here so King G7 will only move
because if you go to E7 Rook F7 you just
lose your queen so you go King G7 and we
need to look at this position a little
bit deeper because black does have a lot
of pieces here but the queen and three
pawns and that's why you have three
pawns actually Queen for a rook and two
minor pieces but this is actually really
strong for a white Rook F1 check
now you have to put the King on an
e-file you can go to the G file the
bishop is hanging so let's say you play
the move King
E6 and now the key move here is H5 with
the idea of Queen H4 also you can
continue playing H6 H7 so this is
actually a winning position for white
thank you for uh that uh VAR we do have
a move after Knight F1 dingler and did
play Rook h8 instead of King G6
you know it was really funny like uh
just uh bringing up vars analysis for a
second Knight F1 King G6 right so in my
mind this is uh great stuff like H5
right
and I think he suggested the move Rook
G8 Rook G8 yeah well he he put Rook G8
on the board and I was thinking in my
mind this is this is really really
brilliant you go H5 check King takes G5
Queen E3 and mate on the next turn right
you have to play King G4 I go Queen and
then you take
home shower cold shower so VAR said oh
you go 93.
Bishop takes E3 and in my mind I was
thinking well H5 check right now H5
check King takes King takes and the
queen takes and and we get but he said
watch the street to be captured but I
thought that Queen tape H5 check and
queen takes I thought was White's
winning idea uh funny stuff uh we do
have Rook h8 VAR and instead of King G6
sorry I wanted to point that out did the
engine approve of ding's uh Choice Rook
h8 yes it's one of the the best
defensive moves Here and Now 93 is
actually important for our Niche to play
to bring this Knight into the game and
so let's see if rookie tonight
93 93 and queen E7 Queen E7 yeah the
best option to protect uh for now you
just for now you're just protecting
everything okay and if you are given a
little bit more time here you want to
play this move Knight B8 and Knight D7
that way now the knife will be protected
and you can maybe run away with the King
right another alternative we have
sometimes you have some Rook H6 ideas
just to sacrifice The Exchange but to
secure the defense against F6 you can
also put the Rook on G6 in that position
so this Rook H6 might be another option
here here uh there is a rook F1 move
here for example to defend uh to try to
maybe open up the f file at some point
that's the best move according to the
ancient series Knight F1 Rook F1 also
you have a knight D5 option here uh but
it's not as strong here 95 because after
Bishop takes D5 e takes D5 Knight B8
Knight will go to D7 uh you do still
have some pressure after long Castle
here but it's not the best option here
so here we have the move Rook F1 as the
best move here for white
Knight B8
bring to bring the Knight to D7 now
Knight F5 check
Bishop has to take it queen queen takes
and now we we're ready to play this move
F4 so now bd7 first all right and here's
uh White actually castles first long
Castle let's see why this move F4
so the point of this move is F4 there is
a rook H5
so pinning uh pinning the bishop here
and this position looks okay
for black takes
Queen takes E5 wow the initiative still
continues but now black is okay here uh
so that's why we don't want to play this
move F4 yet first you go along castle
and uh it's it's an advantage for white
but it's not like there is a clear cut
away for white to just break through and
win the game so you still have to build
up here and you haven't definitely an
advantage here but but Rook F1 it's not
an easy move to find yes sir yeah yeah
just and keep maintaining the pressure
this idea you're making what we could
call a positional uh peace sacrifice
right and we have one result so far as
Wesley so on Fabi called it an early day
at the office I think there was some
disappointment
much more so in the case of Wesley so
I'll be happy to draw and consolidate
his lead he's got half a point lead with
two rounds to go
Championship rounds coming up so okay
very nice and where would you like to
take it yes please in the game uh in
periodine game the positions where we're
looking at King G6 and King even going
to G5
that reminds me of one in soccer A
team's losing yes and there's just a few
minutes left in the game yeah everybody
just comes out and you're right the
goalie explain in the middle right
that's just what it feels like the king
coming all the way to G6 G5 a good a
good General always leads his army into
battle and let's jump to Bucharest as
Christian caught up with his podcaster
Bobby
thanks yes Bobby uh first of all
um not a very difficult day at the
office for you did you expect that from
Wesley did you expect this mild strategy
from him I wasn't sure I thought either
he's going to play E4 and go for uh for
a Sharp fight I thought E4 would be a
sign that he's he's going for it and D4
would be a sign that he wants to rock up
keep it solid which he sometimes tends
to do and it really depends on his mood
I think and I thought it was 50 50.
sometimes he goes for a win and he's
very dangerous and sometimes he plays
super super solid and you don't really
have any chances to win or
um because I mean he plays like super
um
like super accurate chess in general
so when he played the cattle and I
thought it's it's sort of
I'm playing a solid line I mean
it's most likely we're going to reach
this position after Bishop C6 and I
wasn't sure exactly like he played
recently one of the most topical Minds
so I mean he played Bishop D2 against
Anish and Vikings day
and I felt a little bit stupid because I
couldn't remember how the game went even
though I saw it this morning
I wasn't sure if it was A5 Queen D3 or
Knight E4 here
but I thought maybe the game on A5 Queen
D3 Bishop B4 I wasn't 100 sure if this
was the game it seems to have been a
game of Wesley but with the black pieces
against Shanklin
uh I'm not sure you should have done
now we're out of the game we're out of
commission so uh not much happened in
this game I mean he could have played on
it at the end I think
um after I played H5 I I just didn't
really see how to free my pieces so I
wanted to create some counter play on
the king side and I think he could have
played on like he's he's probably a tiny
bit better but it is more or less an
equal position
um I wasn't opposed to his repetition
repetition well you're the man to catch
in this tournament right now you have
some followers that's reach a report
have a point behind Wesley was one of
them but obviously he's not going to be
able to catch up with you did you manage
to see any of the other games any uh
spectacular things happening in your
opinion well unicious game is
interesting uh against sting this is
very dangerous for blackhead looked like
and
I wasn't sure I was going can we have a
look at this game now it's over
unfortunately it's over because I'm 100
sure how to do the uh
how to get out of where you placed us
Bobby
but that's okay I can figure this out
we will figure it out at some point but
not right now I
know yeah that's an interesting game I I
think I was a pretty surprised by his
rookie shape move
but I was even more surprised that Anish
got like such a dangerous position like
such a such a dangerous attack like if I
move 10. did you analyze that because we
know you're an expert in the Italian as
well with white and black you play it I
haven't checked this exact position but
I mean I I also might have checked it
but forgotten I'm not sure it just
didn't really ring a bell
of course sacrifices like this are
always possible and uh
yeah I I thought that Bishop takes F2
was was a critical move after Knight F1
but I guess there's something wrong with
it I wasn't sure I thought that Rook h8
is like looking super super dangerous
what he played and I don't know what's
going on but um I do hope he survives
obviously because uh like it doesn't
really help my tournament if another
person goes on plus one yep if on each
goes on plus one and I'm also a bit
worried about Jan's position although
that one is more or less balanced yeah
at least objectively according yeah but
it looks a bit more pleasant for white
end and Jan is a bit down on time so uh
of course there's positions of that but
like let's say in terms of decisive
games that could happen those are the
two that I would point to and Richie's
position looked level to me looked quite
level but anything could happen it is
double it is like let's say an
imbalanced position
what are the feelings that you
experience when you've just finished a
long tournament uh you know that sapped
into your energy levels and then you
have to play chess once again because it
seems to be there's something that's
been hitting both Jan and and ding
from your experience
well I what can I say they're not
playing too well
Jan has solidified a bit he had this
like really rough patch where he clearly
got tilted
against me
um and and then against Maxine like this
was like very clear tilt I mean his game
against vaccine was to
put it politely completely atrocious
um it was I mean he'll tell you the same
thing that it was a really bad game he
would he was better and he just started
to shuffle his pieces
basically back and forth while Maxine
improves his position with every move so
those two games were clear tilty seems
to have uh come back come back to his
senses at least he's playing like
relatively normal chess
um ding like I don't understand his game
yesterday
you know the funny thing is the line he
played against
Wesley I was considering planning as
young because it is sort of a way to get
a fight but when I was looking at the
line it felt like it's just very healthy
for black basically you can make any
move and why it takes a great deal of
risk moving pieces back and forth like
Queen D4 Queen D1
um but like the way that he played it
just showed like a lack of feeling of
danger I mean
you
like if you compared to a king's Indian
or something which is like a typical
position from the structure you know
usually white is castled and has
everything aimed at the D5 Square here
white uh moved the queen around back and
forth and then moved the knight from G1
E2 to F4 to H3 yeah and so usually you
don't want to take lost a lot of tempees
three three moves to play your knight on
H3 and black is completely developed
like it just felt feels wrong so his
play felt really bad in that game
yesterday in general his Play Feels
like something's very off yeah yeah well
thank you for that assessment Fabi will
let you get some rest before the
championship rounds tomorrow you play
Anish with the white pieces and you
finish it off with Richie report
um how are you going to approach this
couple of games
yeah I'll try to put pressure on it it's
not easy I usually struggled to create
winning chances against him and he's
like super super solid uh very well
prepared player
um very level-headed so
sometimes difficult to create chances
against him but I'll try and and the
last round we'll see what the tournament
situation is thank you very much Fabi
we'll see you tomorrow guys back to you
thank you Christian thank you Fabi and
indeed let's just take a look at the at
the position between Anish and dingler
and where Fabi himself was calling for
Bishop takes F2 Shaq rather than Rook h8
because he just felt that this position
is dangerous for black
we saw a position uh VAR was showing
I'll do a different move order to get
there Queen E7 Knight F5 check Bishop
takes F5 Queen takes at five night back
to B8 Rook to F1 the mysterious Rook
move as we prep the move F2 F4 Knight D7
castles was the main line of uh VAR and
just keeping the pressure this is a
long-term peace Sacrifice
from White's perspective he gets two
pawns but Black's pieces are like tied
up and it's only with you know the
utmost accuracy uh we think that Ding
would will be able to save this this is
not a pleasant position even with the
most precise
and be able to save it if white also
makes all the best moves exactly exactly
we do have Knight E3 and let's just
check in on Richie uh Rapport uh
something was going on in the the game
with the ACT this is
um well I mean a rivalry let's say uh
who is the best player in Romania these
are the two candidates and they're up
against each other today
um we've been seeing some chewing and
throwing also from uh Daniel dayoc uh
he's maneuvering the pieces around the
boardvar but has he accomplished
all that much
um I don't think he accomplished that
much white has a pleasant position here
I like the knights on D3 and F4 yeah and
at some point when it's all prepared I
think he will maybe try to open up the
position with the G4 but right now also
Richie is trying to get some space on
the queen side that's why I played the
move a4a5 the current position he's
slightly better
and I think what Knight B8 is he's
trying to maybe bring that Knight to C6
and try to put pressure on A5 at some
point maybe 97 96 but let's take a look
uh the best moves in this position now
for white and black here so Knight B8
played so again one of the ideas is to
try to play G4 to open up the position
here so let's say if you play the move
Rook G1 here
now the idea is to play G4 so black can
play the move Queen G5 here first try to
put pressure on this diagonal to try to
discourage the move G4 here so if we
still play G4 here I think it's it's
very risky because you're going to be
now pinned here so after Knight D7 it's
not easy to get out of this pin here so
we might see after Queen G5 a move like
a queen E2
and now we see the move Knight C6 come
in now putting some pressure on A5
to play A6
you can play B5 or you can also play the
move B6 here
now since we already played A6 we are
free to move this stroke into the game
so okay one and uh Queen you can play
Queen H6 for example or Rook G7 it's
it's very solid position for black as
well here it's not easy to break through
here and of course G4 is one idea but
it's going to be very difficult with the
bishop sitting on this six uh engines
give a small Advantage for white here
but again I think we're gonna see lots
of maneuvering in this position and
before we see any kind of concrete
breaks happening in the position I
always felt that these long maneuvering
games are are Richies uh
pets
shop if you will that's what he likes he
loves these uh maneuvering games and if
you just look at Black's pieces like
right now Black's minor pieces the night
on B8
and the bishop on D6 and you go okay
okay they're there and then I would ask
you the question where did they come
from so if you go back like quite a
number of moves so here we are
the Bishops on H6 right
the Knight went to G4
so take it this picture in your mind now
it's on G4 Bishops on H6 and then we're
just gonna jump immediately to the
current position and the Knight on G4
went back to B8
no I would just think that so that night
never developed you know right right the
Knight just goes all the way back from
G4 to B8 the bishop went okay I can
understand that maybe you felt the
bishop was a little bit better
centralized you cover E5 you still
attack F4 but it just feels to me like
black is kind of thrown away a lot of
Tempe now Richie hasn't done that much
but it does feel like he's the one who's
been making you know tiny incremental uh
progress
and for those of you who may just be
joining us uh early uh So what had
happened is the we had the ceremonial
first move and a footballer a manager of
a football club came out and played D4
and Richie just let it stay like that's
fine and uh Daniel felt like excuse me
but you're the one who should be making
the move not the footballer so take the
move back and then play D4 and Richie
said look dude I'm gonna play D4 it's
already there I don't I'm not gonna take
it back and play and then they uh
[Music]
that was your preference it was because
you know I understand what you were
saying like you like the chaos you like
the tactics give me give me action uh I
like simplified positions where I have
the advantage now when I look at what
happened in the game
and I'm sitting there saying to my way
of thinking I love black I love Black's
position because of the compromise King
set I also think on the last move could
have been played Queen G5 check first I
think we're looking at something similar
well the problem is is
uh if I get to play Rook G1 I could do
something nasty right so like at some
point you're going to recapture
and I he that there was that moment
where you could play Knight E5 I think
VAR was pointing out uh tactically you
might be able to get away with Knight E5
here too risky a little bit right okay
so that was why he recaptured but he's
leaving
farrugia in a situation where the
imbalance of the minor pieces
my favor
black considerably like this Knight
teleports itself to some juicy Square
please say that black is preferable
even though we have double pawns the
openg file as you just pointed out to me
yes the G7 square is something where it
can Target as as long as we have Queens
on the board still it's a well but again
uh okay well let's take a look he did
play Rook D1 that's the tempo move okay
so the other Rook to do I'm a little
surprised with Rook F to do one I guess
he was thinking that maybe he could
exploit the
um
planning to play on the king side I
would like to keep the Rook on F1 so I
can move it to G1 okay fair okay so
let's say this one yes yeah rook and
let's say I go back and B5 and B5 and
check
so I I usually want to combine the move
check Knight E5 uh VAR pointed out this
very nice tactic from a previous line
which went uh Queen g495
and uh I think we'll agree we'll we we
prefer Black's position again thanks to
the compromised Pawn so B5 Queen G5
check are you still with me you like
this you have to move your king
yes and uh King H1 okay
King H1 and let's go right Knight E
Knight Eve well wait wait yeah
all right
at four I don't think it's perpetual oh
I'm paying them I was only looking at
Queen H5 yeah I I was hoping that I I'd
have
as they would say a perpet in the pocket
but uh so
um yeah I I I I feel like that this is a
kind of a risk free for uh nepo
um but okay uh you know sometimes I do
get a little bit overtly excited about
weak structures and the dynamic play uh
is a compensation a VAR Jump Right In as
we're discussion this discussing uh the
position by the way uh I can understand
what you were saying about Rook on A1 to
D1 Rook F1 to D1 was was Ali raisa's A
Move
um
long term I like black uh what's what
what's the engine say about this current
position engine of course says it's zero
zero zero zero yeah there is one idea I
think maybe Jan made a very slight
inaccuracy when he captured on D6 I
prefer the move Rook takes D6 I will
show you there is a specific reason why
in this position because we stick with
the queen you actually you know that
Rook D1 is going to come you're gonna
have to move the queen again so I'm a
little bit surprised he didn't just
stick with this one but it's possible
that maybe he missed something because
Rook D6 is a natural move so B5 is the
only thing that he needs to worry about
here right now you have the smooth Queen
check and I think he perhaps overlooked
this idea because otherwise it makes
more sense to take with the Rook here I
think he simply overlooked that when he
plays this move Queen G4 there is this
move 95 that it's gonna make the
difference and I already showed this
line in the previous variation Bishop E5
you have Queen E5 and if you take on G5
we have this Knight F3 check and you
pick up the the pawn on G5 but if you
play here let's see Queen G5 check if
you try to just move the King right King
H1 then you have the move Knight E5 very
important to blockade this diagonal so
Rook G1 and Rook G7 doesn't come with a
Tempo here right so and now if you play
the move Rook G1 here then there is
Queen F5 threatening to take on H3 also
threaten the pawn on F3 essentially
forcing the move Bishop takes E5 and we
know after a move like Bishop B5 why
can't why can never be better here so
it's just uh you have to just make sure
you you are not worse here so I think I
prefer the move Rook D6 definitely in
the current position after the move
Queen C7 alireza has a little bit of uh
initiative here after the move B5
because you don't have a good Square for
the Knight to go to here
and you and I have to put a knight on E7
okay
and I was looking at uh even taking the
pawn on A7 I was looking at this option
and here you basically sacrifice a pawn
for an initiative you play the move
Knight G6
Rook to d8 Rook to D1 but not not an
easy position to play uh for for for
black especially because you it looks
like you're just down a pawn there is no
strong attack but now that Queen comes
in and suddenly after Queen H4 uh
there's there is some Contra play here
with this Pawn on uh H3 being weak let's
say if you play King G2 then you're
losing now to the move Rook D2 because
Queen C8 will be met by Knight f8 so not
easy to spot but this Knight gets on G6
you're losing you're clearly down a pawn
here but because of the king weaknesses
you have enough Contour play here for
equality
uh thank you uh for that bar again the
is really confounding why did he play
Queen takes D6 that's ridiculous you're
just walking into this Tempo Rook takes
D I mean when you think about it you
know like wait you know I'm looking at
this position this king is weak
full stop end of story your king is weak
if I play Rook takes D6 and it's
actually my turn I'm gonna cheat you and
I play E5 why on Earth wouldn't you want
your rook in this really powerful
attacking position he was worried about
B5 and he wanted the square at E7
available for the night well exactly and
that was I think that's what it's all
about frankly is I think you just got to
this position and he missed 95 that's
what it's all about all right let's uh
jump into some other uh games for uh
just a moment by the way did play Queen
E7 I think that was the best move 93 is
on the board and it's funny I think the
engine according to VAR uh Rook F1
mysterious move as white
you know if white could make the illegal
move F2 F4 it would be brilliant because
then we would really be able to put a
lot of pressure against the Knight on F6
The Rook would come to F1 so what this
move so many options here yeah Knight D5
looks good knight F5 so long Castle I
actually had a problem with Knight D5 so
explain that to me so Bishop takes D5
when when VAR played run takes now we'll
stop for just a second here
did you hear the bishop on C4 crying
like what did you do my I was I was on
this really beautiful diagonal I was
attacking uh the pawn on F7 and now you
blocked my view why why were you
attracted it can get a second life later
we can play long Castle right Queen G3
something like D4 and Bishop D3 so you
can still have a second second Good Life
queen G3 D4 Bishop to D3 okay yeah
because I I just see that Bishop on C4
and you know it's in tears and honestly
there's another idea since night is on
B8 going to D7 to defend the Knight on
F6 I can always play Bishop B5 and
encouraging me to play C6 yeah or I can
play it once you play 97 I go for 35
threatening and then I have to get out
of these so if we just uh made a move
for example uh Knight D7 it should be
five you've got the very nasty idea
Bishop takes a D7 and this is uh still
on the board here this uh terrible pin
um
but I
thought Rook F1 and Knight F5 I would
find myself attracted to Knight F5 uh
very much so so that I could keep the
diagonal open you you saw reasons that
maybe keeping the diagonal close also a
long Castle so we can keep all the
options open exactly uh I like that one
especially uh as well
um VAR uh
uh Nasi and I are you know discussing
the pros and cons of how honest should
be pursuing the attack jump in and clear
our cobwebs yeah it's a very rich
position a lot of interesting options
for white I was just checking to move
along castle and we do have to play this
move Rook F1 I think this is our best as
the best chance for our Niche to get the
big big Advantage here if let's say you
go along Castle here there is a way for
black to get out of trouble here so he
will actually eliminate the ninth here
immediately and solve the problem of
this Knight jumping into D5 F5 and G for
now you have to capture back with a pawn
and he's still under this very
unpleasant pain but now Knight beard
will come into play with this idea once
again we see that this Knight b897 is a
key idea key defensive idea for Block
here so let's say we continue with the
pressure yep Rook hf1
Knight bd7 now defending
F6 and not easy to see how white can try
to increase the pressure in this
position can we double on F5 let's say
Rook D2 or Rook after yeah Rook D2 is
one of the options but now white can
take on c4's black oh sorry black will
take on C4 and after you capture Queen
E6
getting out of the pin just in time yes
just in time and now putting pressure
line for a moment Rook F2 Rook F2 and
once uh you're out of this pin you play
the move Knight H7
capturing on F7 is a dead end capturing
on F7 the the problem at the end of that
line is the bishop on G5 is hanging how
many pawns did I take I've got three
pawns for the Knight right bar yes you
have you have three pounds right now and
a fourth in the pocket fourth in the
pocket the problem is the pawns are the
white pawns are also weak weak so if you
like let's say
um black is actually just winning I'm
also surprised that they're well really
just winning yeah and Counting pawns and
I'm yeah I'm feeling like Midas over
here with the you know the golden coins
well now I think Block's turn he's gonna
say okay now it's my turn to take your
pawns and you're gonna drop
E4 pawn and again the prospects of this
past month it's not very very high you
know because they're not really Advanced
here so you can take on B7 for example
here Rook takes C4 then you got a
problem with the A4 Pawn you're most
definitely dropping the E4 Pawn as well
here so that's why uh this this line
doesn't work very well for white here
the long Castle but we can go back and
look at some other options in that
position instead of the long Castle here
again uh main option is when the queen
is only seven you know now you actually
want to take only three get rid of the
bishop and play the move Queen E6 and I
think now we see why this move Rook F1
is so important here because when this
move is played Bishop E3 does not work
because once you take you don't have
time to take on C4 here because of the
move Bishop F6 here so again this is now
completely winning cash and one thing
also when Fabiano was giving the
interview he pointed out I wanted to
show you guys here he mentioned the
smooth Bishop F2 here which we missed
actually and uh the reason is the
because you cannot take back here on F2
because if you take back actually after
94 black is doing okay in fact this move
it's actually just loses to a very calm
move very clever King E2 here wow you do
not take you do not take one of three
minutes and now actually you're
threatening to take if let's say King G6
played you play Bishop F6 Queen takes F6
you exchange queens and then you are in
a winning end game with the very healthy
extra Pawn here but I thought I just
show you this move kinky too because it
actually
backfires because now you have to move
the bishop and if you move the bishop to
let's say B6 now we can play either
Knight G3 or Knight H2 both moves are
winning and we didn't want to have this
F Pawn in the first place and now Rook
F1 will come with a Tempo putting
pressure here and now we didn't have to
play the move F4 to achieve that so this
actually just simply winning for white
this move after Bishop F2 it's very very
very nice sacrifice of the F2 Pawn but
the combination of sacrificing the F2
Pawn that's okay but then playing the
move King E2
check that guy's Pockets we have a
social media question let's jump right
into it let's see this one is from
Stefan uh from YouTube
yes sir any stories for us about opening
move blunders oh my god oh no we're
gonna be here all day all day
yeah and I I do think
it's uh
more or less one of the tragedies of
modern chess is that the openings have
become so sophisticated and everything
can can rely upon one little subtlety
you you you you get an advantage or you
get nothing all based on one little
subtlety right and so you've got to
remember all of these um
nuances and opening blunders uh I was
playing in the world team championships
in China and it was playing Ilyas Merit
it was the United States versus Israel
and Ben Feingold bless his heart had
been preparing me in this very very
sharp Carl cons and we were going bang
bang bang bang bang and we got to this
position where Ilya went Bang
I was like dude that's not the right
move he made the wrong move he was
supposed to play this other move he
played this move instead and I saw
immediately it's I can take a pawn
so every fiber with every fiber of my
being I wanted to take this Pond but he
got he gets some dangerous dangerous
attacks and much to my great Chagrin I
didn't take the pawn got myself into a
rook in three verses rook and two ending
which was a draw
but immediately after the game oh
yeah I gotta ask you what would even if
I have to take upon
said sorry yeah sir I made a finger
failure
I know
no no no no no no because we go into the
games today expecting our opponents have
checked with the world's super computers
that all of their opening moves or
sounds so we believe them it's easier to
Bluff them sometimes sometimes if you
make an early mistake you can Bluff your
opponent and they'll trust you that this
was prepped exactly how about you
opening blender some horrifying stories
uh I think there was one I was playing
in Bill Switzerland the bill open
tournament and I was on board two or
three playing this Grandmaster over
2600. okay big game and my game is like
broadcasted and I plundered upon on move
three
that was the earliest Wonder of my life
that show is real understanding uh if
you don't mind how did you blunder on
move three what happened you were white
or black I was black okay E4 E4 C6
pets move one it's not easy to blunder
up on and okay Knight C3 Knight C3 D5
yep
and Queenie two
never seen that move Queen that's a bad
move it sure looks like a bad move I
took my time and played G6 that's a
blunder on the phone and he just took on
D5 and his next turn was Queen D5 chat
it was quite embarrassing quite
embarrassing ouch
ouch Jump Right In you're embarrassing
moments or opening blunders if you will
um I'm sure I had a lot of them
yesterday I know but uh last year I
remember I was playing a Chicago open
tournament and I played The slav
Exchange and uh made it made it like a
blunder in opening which I know really
really well my opponent played one of
those Queen B6 moves and attacked my
opponent for some reason I thought I can
sacrifice the pawn and but I I just
didn't remember the line correctly and
end up being down upon it was really
struggling I ended up losing that game
right so even the openings you know well
you still have to be careful to make
sure that you don't blunder one one uh
story comes to mind you probably know
this game the famous blunder of Anatoly
carpool against yes against uh Larry
Christensen well yes Queen the one he
stayed with me uh after uh do you have
that uh yeah I can I can yeah I can
maybe if you remember the moves I can
put the moves in oh I don't remember it
moves I remember it was Queen D1 hitting
the Knight on H5 and hitting the
business there was a bishop on D6 Knight
on H5 and right Queen D1 attacked both
pieces and karpov immediately resigned
right and that was like move 10 so
Larry's staying with me
and I said well what happened so Larry
plays this move Queen D1 on move 10
which attacks a black Bishop on D6 and
attacks a Black Knight on H5 and Anatoly
loses a piece and resigns on the spot
so I said to Larry well what did you do
after the game I said uh would you like
to analyze
I said you didn't he said no no no no I
did not I did not I did not uh let's
jump uh to the game of mvl because we
know that dude is not having the
greatest tournament MBL thanks to his
win over Napo kind is crawling his way
in into the event and if he can do
something with the black pieces today
hey hey hey uh our champion uh our
defending Champion will be back in
business as Judith Polgar might say at
this point
more or less I would say this is kind of
a trench warfare kind of game I think
white is a little bit better I like this
The Outpost C4 but in truth not much is
going on I was very surprised to see
it's coming up this move E5 when I at
first I saw this movie five I said whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa because the problem
with E5 is sure you gain some nice
control over the D6 and F6 squares but
boy losing control of the F5 square is a
French defense player I get a knight to
F5 I start feeling really really good
especially when we get the knight in
Carol can as well exactly especially
when I see an open diagonal maybe one of
the best moves that white can make in
this position is go E5 back to E4 to
stop for the night but okay let's see I
mean that's what it's all about right to
get squares you got to give them and in
this case Duda was expecting that night
on e4 exactly that's what he was
thinking Knight to B6 were caught up
with the players and VAR uh give us the
uh engines assessment uh as M my first
impression is I think that well the
positions likely balanced the movie E5
struck me as wrong
yes I also don't like what uh Duda is
doing and E5 move is definitely
overextending creating a lot of
weaknesses in fact the current position
is actually black is slightly better yes
because the the weak squares will see
that in particular that diagonal the
queen on C6 Bishop B7 you have to be
very careful you move that Knight you're
gonna get checkmated on G2 here so here
I think dude I slowly realizing that you
know perhaps he is the one who needs to
play accurately now and let's take a
look at some of the lines here but I I
think mvl has some chances in this game
now so uh Bishop B3 is the best option
here right so you you have to uh try to
recapture now on C4
with the bishop so Knight takes C4
Bishop C4 you really need to spawn on D3
to defend this Knight otherwise you're
going to have some big problems on this
diagonal but here uh black can play Rook
d8 there is not much you can do on an A5
you sure you're not going to be able to
enter here so you can play look Rook d8
that will give you some options with the
move Knight D4 here
and uh so engine is suggesting this move
H4 which I'm not uh I'm not sure
that I want to do here in this position
but let's say you play a normal move
okay one okay just to see a plan for
black black can actually play the move
even G6 in this position now you want to
put a Pawn on H5 here to permanently
secure the Knight on F5 here again black
is the only one who can play here the
bishop one F2 is very passive not doing
much let's say B3 H5 for example Rook A2
you can't even play now now you can
consider this move Knight D4
after improving the position and if
Bishop takes Rook D4 black is the only
one with some chances but I think with
accurate play I think white white should
be okay here as well but uh some chances
I see for mvl in this game perhaps to
try to take the full point all right
thank you for that bar yeah I I thought
E5 was a bit of a overreach let's jump
to the world champion
uh dingler in and let's just see how
Okay uh Rook F1 that very hidden move uh
was not discovered by Anish and the
Castle's Queen side was a mistake we
were expecting this Rook F1 and this is
where Bishop takes E3 and Bishop takes
E4 uh what VAR had said was an
equalizing move but dingless ding missed
that chance and he played the move Rook
A8 to G8 keeping uh on issues of that
advantage in life again Rook F1 kind of
a hidden move
Knight F5 check uh uh and by the way I
think now I have one looks more natural
Rook A8 G8 instantly yeah he played that
instantly uh wow I'm just looking maybe
he thought that was the only move well
okay but by the way what on Earth does
Rook G8 do explain that one to me
because that's uh that's a little bit of
a headscreen typically it would be an
idea for your king to run away precisely
but with the Knight hanging your king
ain't going in well maybe after Knight
b897 then the king can run okay so let's
go here here
here here right so you've got one two
moves and your goal the problem is I'm
not gold not gold even after King runs
away I'm still pinned on F6 true so it
doesn't really help it doesn't help that
much but you will at least maybe have
the the chance for Rook takes G5 on a
good day right
maybe so here the desirable F4
to play Rook F1
unfortunately is met by a check
and Bishop takes F4 any trade of the
dark squared vicious would be a welcome
welcome welcome relief for black so Rook
A8 to G8
um VAR just tell me what what's the
hidden
hidden purpose of Rook A8 to G8
no I think he's trying to play Knight B8
and ibd7 and try to go King fa after but
I'm really surprised he played this move
so quickly and he did not even consider
the move Bishop E3 which actually would
have been uh pretty straightforward and
take only C4 after that and play Queen
E6 right in the current position white
has a really a large Advantage he can
actually play either Rook hf1 or Rook
df1 but you need to put one of your
Rooks on a a file here and that way the
bishop E3 move is no longer possible so
let's take a look for example uh how the
game can develop here Rook df1 seems a
little bit more natural because there
might be a need for us to advance this
Pawn at some point and here and here you
cannot take only three because of after
Fe F6 is going to be hanging right so
you have 98's only move sorry not only
every Rook H6 also Anish actually played
Rook H to F1 already HF okay so let's
see I don't think there is going to be
that much of a difference here so so
perhaps another idea I see Rook Jade I
think he wants to play this move guys
Rook H6
he wants to sacrifice The Exchange and
now he wants to put the Rook on G6 ugly
so uh for example now if we take on H6
King takes H6 right
and um
again black is hoping to somehow move
the king to f80 Knight D5
take you can take with the the Knight
because after Ed you're losing a piece
so you have to take back with the bishop
Pawn takes and now Knight goes to
uh goes to d8 actually it's I'm not sure
why but 98 is better here than Knight B8
uh a bit of a strange score for the
Knight to go to and here white continues
with uh G4
a couple of pawns for yeah you have two
pumps already another option you have in
this position uh perhaps rookie one and
D4 is another moment but okay G4 and
um
King if you the C6 is the best move you
really need to try to get rid of this D5
Pawn so C6 is your best option but again
very hard to play these moves they're
not very natural more natural is to play
let's say Rook G6 and try to get the
king to G7 but in this case D4 is very
strong because you have a bishop D3 idea
and you're going to be putting pressure
here white has actually more material at
the moment rook and two pawns for two
pieces again the king is still exposed
and a good very good winning chances
here for anishikiri well the the crazy
part for me VAR is a move like Rook H6 I
don't even understand why that provokes
the response Bishop takes H6 am I
worried about Rook G6 and Rook tags so
for example just a quick question for
you in this moment he did play the move
Rook
age F1 and I think of a reasonable
argument could also be made for work on
D1 so we we've seen lines where H4 and
Rook H3 uh comes uh Rook H6 I mean if I
go check
you've got to take I take and you go
Rook G6 I mean what else right and I go
H4 isn't this just
unpleasant I mean you just you to say
the list yeah I mean I want it to play
King B1 and I want to play F4 I feel
like I got two pawns you know the Rooks
on G8
Queen D7 but it's not available
E7 is an idea so again uh it shows equal
right now in this position here you can
continue with H5 as the main line right
Knight takes H5 Rook H1
is the only move
and now you can even play
Rook H2 to double up the Rooks wow
very very sharp still F6
Bishop D2
Knight F7 trying to consolidate Queen F3
Knight goes on F4 wow and uh
actually you white is just playing down
a piece and it's still not easy exactly
because after capture Rook takes now you
have a G3 thread yeah I would think that
black is winning you would think so
until you say well how am I going to
meet G3 G3 Queen H5 is very strong so
you have to you have to try to play this
move c6d5 very quickly you need to shut
down this diagonal well one of the
things that this line shows VAR and what
we've been seeing throughout the whole
game is this positional peace sacrifice
it's not like you know a combination
with talk talk talk but rather It's a
combination where we're playing
improving moves and just saying to our
opponent go ahead and try to improve as
we get ready for a break we have a
special for you we ask the players
imagine that you just played a really
really tough game in the previous round
how do you recharge your batteries and
get ready for the next day these are
their answers we'll see on the other
side of the break
[Music]
this tournament is very long and very
taxing physically how important is it
for you to relax and re-energize after
each and every game the games are
extremitauring of course as we as we go
with the tournament it gets more and
more tiring and also there's lots of
emotions and lots of physical exhaustion
basically So eventually you're going to
run out of energy from from every
possible aspects and then you are just
going to be working that I think the
best players are the ones who you can
cope with this situation or basically
the Regis situation as late as possible
in the tournament or who can complete
the best and to come on overlay their
way through the fatigue and the bunch of
errors that will eventually creep in and
um and they can bounce back quickly it's
important uh if you think differently
see my games from the match yeah of
course learn to rest after this long and
top championship match
I didn't expect it's so tough that I
expected but well today after the
opening ceremony I think I was
uh get into the
atonement I'm ready for tomorrow's game
yeah I think very important say it's at
least half of what the most important
thing you need to do during retirement
you need confidence and a lot of rest a
lot of sleep your brain cannot function
without getting a good night's rest so
you have to balance it with preparation
during their month a lot of things can
happen mistakes happen uh so you kind of
need to be ready those big moments yeah
I think classical chess is the only
format where you have just one game to
prepare for and that really makes a
difference because you can focus on a
particular player or the particular
color and bring your best ideas and have
the time to work them out and get them
into your system so I think that's
that's quite exciting and
You know despite the rapid and place
catching on you still see what classical
chess has to offer and uh kind of
spectacular games we see yeah for me
sleeping is very important you should
have a sleep at least eight nine hours
because if you will play for six seven
hours so you have to have a lot of rest
if you're tired you cannot mentally be
ready and think
so it's very important physically also
and maintenance
now definitely I
prioritizing after the games you know
getting some rest I'm getting ready for
the next games and obviously I'm also
doing that on a daily level
who is uh
physical Sports and trying to increase
my my stamina and such to to be ready
for tournaments that are you know tough
and quite exhaustic okay
a rest time is important probably for
every player because they need some rest
and to prepare for the next stop I think
it's almost like the second most
important after just playing good chess
yeah sometimes you you know there are of
course strong emotions involved in the
gains and you have to you have to
recover
sometimes you have to you know forget
about the rose game
I think we saw from a match that when
when people get tired they're you know
they're starting to make decisions that
are atypical of them
they they make mistakes that they
normally wouldn't make so stress and
tiredness that can really play a huge
role in terms of lowering your quality
or like at those critical moments you
know and especially when you're low on
time and sometimes you you have to like
switch to Instinct and you just need
like your full capacity so if if you're
a bit tired if you're a bit stressed
these things they you might not even
realize it but they really can play a
huge role
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
six rounds of play we are in the seventh
round only one result so far yeah so we
had one quick drop behind Wesley so and
Fabiano caruana well after that peaceful
outcome the four games that remaining
are uh full of uh fight especially the
game between Anish giri and dingler and
that's got our attention as on on each
made a long-term peace sacrifice and
he's still pursuing the attack farouja
uh grab the pawn
something I really love but on the other
hand I'm not a I'm not a fan of this
last move by Ian he played the move Rook
A8 and in my mind's eye I'm thinking
that you know the Rook is actually
really really good on uh d8 and I would
really have been looking for ideas of uh
I don't know Queen D3 and Knight H4 and
maybe on a good day if I could get the
queen out of the way I could go Rook D2
but the move Rook A8 is being has been
played and across the whole stage it
feels like fights are breaking out
everywhere uh VAR jump in and tell us
about the game between ferrugia and NEPA
yeah I think uh fiorusha has very good
winning chances now A8 was a big
inaccuracy and uh let me show you first
what Jan had to do in order to keep the
equality here he had to play this move
Knight H4 here which you know makes
sense because you bring the Knight on F5
but Knight itself not gonna do anything
here you need really need this Knight
here to put pressure
so now you're attacking the pawn on F3
and you need to protect this because if
you this Pawn because if you play the
move E5 then you run into this move
E5 fantastic move now attacking the pawn
on H3 and if you take with the queen
then you have an idea simply forking yes
so you can't really do that so the best
move here is to play Queen H5
try to defend and for a moment it seems
like what's the what's really the point
now you have to move the Knight but
actually you go back here Knight F5 and
now the queen is completely out of place
and you have some Queen D2 ideas coming
up here as well next so the move E4 is
very logical try to remove the knight
from here and here is a beautiful idea
Knight G3
Queen D2 yeah yeah and now if you take
Queen goes on D2 attacking the bishop
and you try to consolidate with Queen E5
now everything looks like it's protected
but check I have a Perpetual now
King F1 uh King H1 Queen F3 King G1 and
uh you continue with this of course
there was one more idea there in this
position after the move Knight G2
there's the smooth Queen G4
and now there is threatening made on G7
so you play the move Knight E2 check
King goes on G2 and now yeah you have F5
you can also play F6 here uh in this
position but you can play for example G5
and now the Rook is under attack and you
also have the strong F4 Square so this
shows equal equal position now after the
move Rook A8 white can play Queen E5
and now putting pressure on G7 and
getting ready to play the move E4 here
and if you capture the pawn with Rook A4
E4 attack in the Knight
Knight cannot move anywhere because of
the queen G7 mate so has to play Knight
D4 and now we play a simple move King G2
and now there is a threat of Rook D1 as
well here putting a pressure on the pin
and you have to do something so Rook
before could be played and now very
strong move Rook C7 comes in attacking
the queen
and
Queen goes to d8 Rook takes B7 now
threatening Rook B8 and white has a very
nice Advantage but this didn't happen
because alireza just played the move
Queen B4 which is not the best move here
and most of his Advantage uh you know
drops still a little bit better here but
I guess he didn't want to allow some of
these complications and he's just trying
to hang on to the A4 Pawn here but now
Jan has a few options here he can play
the move Queen D3 which makes a lot of
sense activating the queen and looking
at some potential 93 ideas another
option here is also to play Queen d8 and
now try to bring the queen into the game
from the side of the board as well here
and also Queen d8 is preventing the
advance of the a pawn as well here still
a little bit better for white here but
black has some chances I think now well
anything that gets the black queen
nudging towards the king side I I'm I'm
all for it and we have it tweet let's
take a look I'll see you let's see what
we've got
done this is from Alabama Sean the
question is what's more important
openings or end games that's the
question if you got an answer please
write to us at St Louis chess club and
scholasticcenters.com
um wow I've always thought it was the
endings
hence what level you're at right it
absolutely that's the end for these guys
the tournament we're looking at right
now I would say openings matter right
because they're so good in the endings
so what comes first the chicken or the
egg in my particular case I I feel that
I made progress as a chess player when I
studied the end games at the start that
is to say you know if I just give you
the rules of Chess you won't understand
anything about coordination nothing but
if I give you a king and a rook versus a
king you understand that to win with the
Rook your king and Rook have to work
together and to coordinate if I give you
a king and two Bishops
and I only have a lone King you're going
to learn how to coordinate those Bishops
with your king So for me learning the
end games helped me understand how the
pieces coordinate with one another and
if you study the openings and you have
no idea what coordination of the pieces
is like
good positions out of the opening but
that one leads well without
understanding yeah exactly you won't be
able to convert to a win from just a
better opening position if you don't
know how to play with the pieces uh
coach Jump Right In I mean obviously
with the students the strength of the
students that you work with you probably
focus on the openings at their stage in
their careers but for amateur players
for amateur players definitely I would
say start with the end games make sure
you know your basic end games your king
and Pawn in games the first your
opposition your diagonal opposition
distant opposition these are the first
thing I normally teach the players who
are new to the game just to understand
that plus maybe triangulation at some
point which is a little bit more
complicated I think and then you can
first start with openings and I think
once you get good maybe you're like over
1000 rating then you already start
studying some openings so with my
students from Saint Louis University we
do spend a lot of time on openings but
we also do a lot of in-game studies
these are difficult studies where you
see a position where it doesn't look
like likely you can try to find a win
but you have this different ideas very
uh unusual ideas so we do spend a lot of
time even with a very strong players on
end game studies yeah thank you for that
far and by the way it's interesting you
said a thousand for me it was always
1200. when you get to 1200 you
understand a lot about Chess I mean
keeping in mind like that out of a
hundred people only one percent joins
the USCF right everybody's playing in
Parks but they don't even know what
tournament an organized tournament chess
is all about and uh 1200 if you play
1200 reviews I would even say up to 1500
you don't really need to focus on the
openings yeah as long as you follow the
general rules of
for the center and make sure your king
is safe by Castleton exactly let's just
jump back into the game of dingler in
because we Anish Gary and ding Loren
because when we left it uh Rook F1 grade
and one of the questions we're asking
ourselves is why did Anish leave his
Rook on D1 well I've got an answer and
the answer is he wanted to play D3 D4
which makes perfect sense if we can in
in combination get to play Knight F5
check and F2 F4 we can freeze this
bishop out of the game ding of course
understands that and he played takes
takes and Knight D7 okay after Knight D7
E5 but look at that D5 yes right and but
our conclusions were favorable for white
right yes but we probably can improve
for black Globe okay show me why D5 I
trapped your Bishop so let's go for 95
still look Knight E5 okay you're forking
my queen and my bishop and I'll fall for
it check I'll take it and I'll take the
queen back and I will not take on E3
I'll not fall for that again oh no
please so Bishop takes 23 check is met
by the very surprising uh response F
takes E3 check don't reach for the
bishop so you're not going to do that
you're going to take it
and we've got a Bishop's of opposite
color position what's the body count
what is a pawn
Rook takes G2 black position has
definitely improved it's not the the the
the the nice extra Pawn I had I had
hoped for which explains why Anish
played E5 first takes D5 a combination
of moves were very uh used to seeing I
want to say because it by playing
E5 first we've stopped 95. in the
meantime the bishop strap what you're
going to do welding
Laren said well I'm going to get out of
this pin I mean the feeling of
Liberation must just be great right
you're just like
and it's also
and we're attacking the the bishop we're
anticipating any captures on E6 will be
met by Bishop takes E3 check to the king
F takes E3 something that we've always
been wanting to do and then we can go
Queen take C4 check King B1 Queen takes
E6 and black is kind of golden because
he's gotten
rid of so many pieces and gotten out of
the pin how is uh unleash gonna deal
with Queen B4 mark
well there's only one move in this
position it's a complete chaos on the
board right now Yasser there's so many
different possibilities even earlier
dink had an option to play Knight C6
instead of Knight bd7 but in the current
position Anish has to find the only move
to keep the advantage which is Queen E2
here
not intuitively obvious either because
you're a queen which has been doing this
great service of keeping that Knight in
a pinquini tube defends the bishop which
I get the bishop on E6 fortunately from
White's point of view isn't running away
uh it's still trapped and how do the
lines continue yeah it's very
interesting how the uh the line
continues here guys so Queenie two
played if he plays he has to play this
move otherwise there's no Advantage so
the the best way for black to play is
Bishop takes E3 okay so it looks very
dangerous after a few right a file is
now open the bishop is trapped here
right but you have to spell bishop G4
sacrificing the bishop so and if you
capture immediately then there is this
Temple move Knight E4 and attacking the
bishop here and there's some Knight G3
ideas as well here so so I have to take
on F6 first yes it's better to take on
F6 first Knight takes F6 now now you
take on G4 and again once the body count
extra Pawn for white extra Pawn but the
attack has kind of fizzled now Rook H4
is the best move to put pressure on G4
white needs to consolidate the position
of the king and put the King on B1 and
still an advantage for white here Rook
takes G4 again Rook F6
does not work because there is a move
Queen C4 actually picking up the the
bishop here so black is doing okay here
so after Rook G4 white needs to play
Bishop D3 but the character of the
position has changed a lot it still
shows Advantage for white but it's not
so easy to understand uh exactly what's
going on here you do have you do have
there's no even extra Pawn here so let's
say before you have Bishop C2
and uh Queen D6 black can try to
consolidate the position so Advantage
for white but not easy to navigate
through this complicated variations
beginning with Queen E2 which I just
already played it he did yes wow I I
mean it was it would be like I have to
go through a long list of candidate
moves in this position I understand that
capturing on E6 doesn't has no payoff
in fact it just simply doesn't work uh
so I I might be going with b2b3 thinking
to myself okay I've got a protect me I
might be going with Bishop to A2 this
bishop of strap you know I'm
prejudiced in the sense that I'm
thinking my Queen's active and good on
the F3 yeah so first of all I have to
overcome my own Prejudice that the queen
is not actually uh very well placed on
F3 in that it's important to just defend
the bishop and then to see the move
Bishop G4 I think we'll uh not have an
easy time finding that movie again I
think for a lot of uh I I mean
when your backs to the wall and there's
nothing else for you to do except Play
Bishop G4 I think you find Bishop G4
it's not a move that that comes
intuitively easy but on the other hand
you don't want to allow D5 Tech C6 sorry
not so yeah I think there's some other
more logical looking moves yes at least
that's that's what I think instead
it's the current position yep but if I
just take Bishop H3 there you go that's
a very young bag and then oh the
training is working I'm so proud okay uh
and run with the king king f8 maybe
which was the whole purpose of Rook h8
initially followed by Rook G8 is that
the black king can get on its uh hiking
uh boots I mean I'm not loving Black's
position but I probably would play H4
myself just because again I mean this
Knight will find
what a gorgeous home on the F5 Square
it's like you still you still have a lot
of
I'm gonna say work ahead of you I just
feel like my king is a little bit well
is a lot better uh more protected King
needs to teleport to B8 very very very
very very very quickly okay that's one
uh game uh the faruga nepo the
imbalances when we left it we left it
about here I didn't understand this move
Rook d8 I love the move anything that
goes kingside something like Queen to D3
with the idea of Queen E2 and Rook to D
I thought but nepo
played a strange move Rook A8 taking
away what I thought was an active rook
and he's going Pond grubbing Queen E5
would have given Ali Reza a very nice
Advantage as VAR showed us instead Queen
B4 a natural reaction I want to protect
my Pawn we were looking at Queen d8 and
queen G5 and anything that goes there
you know there just go to the king site
I like this move Queen D3 and ever since
that appeared
Perugia once it went into a tank
uh a Time think I mean to suggest and
what is the current clock times right so
ferocious down to 12 minutes okay and
then postal has 29 minutes
so farouza is burning a lot of clock and
especially after this move Queen D3 the
queen D3 hit him as a a surprise bar
he's it doesn't look completely happy
uh actually uh White has a very strong
move here he does he finds this movie
Arusha he would have excellent winning
chances and it's not easy to see though
the move is Bishop E5 here Bishop E5 yes
and now you're controlling a lot of the
squares the Knight wants to go to but
the key is there is a tactical shot
Knight takes E3 there that looks like a
a killer blow actually yes and you're
threaten Queen G6 check as well it looks
like just a huge blunder right but after
the move Knight takes E3 white has the
move Queen E4 I can perhaps show this on
the board here so Bishop E5
Knight takes E3 and looks like now if
you capture Queen E3 check you can lose
your Rook Queen G6 Queen G2 is coming up
but after this move Queen E4 you're
consolidating the position if you move
the coin anywhere Queen takes C3 you're
down a piece and after the recapture
only four F takes for your knight is
simply trapped
what a cookie uh yeah and if you play F6
just simply Bishop F4 and it's a winning
Advantage
trap in the center of the board right
quite rare that is that that's nice so
there's a TR okay but I understand you
play Bishop E5 great power to you
uh but I don't have to fall for your
Cheapo Knight takes E3 can't I instead
play I don't know F6 Queen E2 anything
that uh uh let's let's look at that sure
Queenie twist actually looks like the
very best move here sure let's take
let's start out with this move now
you're putting pressure on F3 and white
will play the move Queen to G4 Queen DG
protecting and also getting ready to
play the move E4 okay and uh
but uh Yasser we have a move A5 is
played by alireza which is what queen B4
was all about I want to keep my pawn and
I want to push it Bishop E5 was a
difficult move to be sure but A5 now
what's going on so first we need to uh
make sure this Knight E3 doesn't work
let's really quick quickly look at that
idea if Knight takes E3 here then simply
captures Queen takes E3 just want to
make sure there's no perpetuals here so
you play King G2 and now if Queen E2
check in this position you have to play
the move key in G3 and looks like no
more checks here and everything is
protected Bishop is guarded by the queen
so white is winning in this variation if
you play the move Queen G5 check then
you can play simply King H1 and again
there are no more checks and after the
move Queen G4 you will consolidate the
position so Knight E3 does not work
immediately and black needs to find this
move here so a it's a tough move to find
but it makes sense the bishop is very
strong on this diagonal you need to
smooth F6 to try to reduce the pressure
in a lot of these variations and try to
make this bishop passive here after F6
uh it's not easy to see how white is
gonna make a progress here you can't
really Advance the pawns anymore at the
moment and engine is suggesting a bishop
A1 for example not an easy move to find
yeah and
yeah we have Queen E2 played right and
this is a looks like a blunder once
again we see the same thing guys Yan is
rushing for no reason he's got 27
minutes to think and he is rushing
trying to put opponent in time pressure
and time and time again we see the same
thing he's doing and blowing away the
good positions here now or why is this a
blunder now I think alireza is simply
winning guys six
sorry with what 86.
but you don't respect the pawn I mean he
played Queen E2 with the expression
the problem is this movie this beautiful
move Queen G4 and now the Quince will
come off the board and the end game is
just going to be pretty much hopeless
and if you try to you don't have a good
way to keep the Queens on them you can
go that smooth but then E4 attack a
forking Queen takes B5 perhaps you maybe
missed something here but they're not
even one option but why can play Bishop
c3n is winning can play the move Rook C2
is winning I just don't really
understand why is Eon moving so fast in
a critical position like this and
alireza with uh simply winning Advantage
if he plays the move A6 right now if
after A6 black just retakes on A6 if you
take on a six then just just be six Pawn
is Unstoppable yeah B7 and Bishop B5 is
coming up so say queen F3 now Queen F3
now
B7 D7 this game immediately over and
yeah you don't have Knight H4 Queen is
Quinn is actually doing a really great
job here covering this H4 Square
controlling the fourth ring and the
queen G4 idea as well so good defensive
uh great opportunity for alireza to win
this game if he finds A6 and he will
catch uh Fabiano which by the way when
you play the move A5
it's very clear you're telegraphing I
want to play A6 I want a pawn
breakthrough I want to play A6 B takes
A6 B6 so that I can play B7 and Rook C8
and that move Rook A8 is getting more
more and more uh despicable because in
those lines where we were playing Knight
takes E3 and going for a Perpetual check
if there was a rook on uh on d8 we
wouldn't be playing her Perpetual chat
we'd be fighting for a Checkmate thanks
to Queen E2 but Queen E2
um played very quickly please that Ali
Russia has eight minutes left for still
12 more moves to go but of course if he
finds this idea of A6 and queen G4 he
won't even need those eight minutes no
he he can play it very very instantly
very very quickly I want to say uh Ace
once you see A6 Queen takes
Queen G4 let's trade Queen so that I can
play B takes once you get here in your
mind's eye you kind of stop Yes you kind
of stop and you go uh oh what's going on
uh if I take the Knight
he takes my Bishop I'm not a happy
camper
and then you go oh but wait a minute all
I have to do is maintain the night is
Frozen the night on F5 under her duress
can't move still a question so let's say
we play Bishop C3 or something like that
I think it was rookie two but Bishop C3
black just for H5 okay well all we have
to do is maintain the attack whether
it's Queen G5 or maybe Queen G2 your
Knight's not moving wow you're stuck
you're stuck any you that's amazing
black has nothing nothing and in the
meanwhile by the way please let me take
a a along another a worthy move
um wow a big opportunity knocking uh for
alireza and he's reaching for the a pawn
come on Ali you can do it
yeah
uh by the way I'm one of those people I
I really strongly advise don't do the
hover board yeah yeah it's a bad habit
because it also tells the opponent where
should I be looking if I keep reaching
for it I'm at the board yeah but
uh when you just play the move
and it can be yeah it can be a real uh
shock because uh I'm in I'm sure in his
Mind's Eye nepo was making this move
Queen E2 in order to defend the pawn on
B7 and just like you said of our why
does he play so fast in those very key
critical moments like this one when he
has 29 minutes well I mean one of the
things is he's been very very successful
throughout his career of putting his
opponents in time trouble but it's the
downside too
so I think it's just not going to work
100 of the time but for him it's it has
worked at the candidates tournaments
very successful but of course he's won
two candidates there will be games where
he'll be punished just for playing too
quickly so A6 so we've been uh focused
on the dingler in and Ali raise the game
let's just go to uh Richie's game
because
uh I gotta tell you I mean I don't know
what the record is for moving pieces
around the board but Daniel diox Knight
uh he's a contender yeah I mean 31 moves
and I suspect the Knight has moved 16
times
you guys are laughing but don't you
think it's been 16 moves the night was
on V8 you know and then it went to C6 it
went back to B8
and it was on G4 earlier and it was on
G4 and it's still not finished and it's
still not finished because it really
wants to go to G6 and chase this Knight
away
um it still seems balanced uh though to
me VAR I don't think either player I
mean there's a weakness on C3
uh there's a double pawns but I don't
think the imbalances give any either
player much chances here yeah I agree
the entrants are showing a very small
Plus for white here it wants to it wants
to play some ideas like Knight H5 at
some point but uh it's it's very small
Advantage I think black should be okay
here with the Knight maybe on G6 Queen
H6 will always be met by uh Queen f8 for
example is an idea in that case so very
hard to break through in this position
you have some problems with the C3 Pawn
as well here let's take a look at some
of the key moves in this position that
can happen here so Knight H5
now you're threatening to play the move
Queen H6 and threatening mate on G7 so
Knight G6 is probably what he's trying
to do and now Queen H6 is going to be
met by the move Queen f8 you don't want
to trade Queens because after you trade
Queens you could be in some serious
trouble because of the weaknesses on C3
in particular there is a tactic Rook D4
and picking up the Rook on C1 here so
you don't want to trade you can come
back only two but really hard to see how
white can make any progress here because
you do have your weakness on C3 and
you're not really free to move your
Rooks to maneuver here and at this point
this G4 plant doesn't look like is going
to do much here for and in fact it can
actually open up your position here so I
wouldn't be completely surprised if they
shuffle a little bit more here and then
perhaps there will be some kind of
repetition but we have a move here
Knight D3 plate
and uh a couple of moves 95 Knight G's
G6 Knight G6 makes sense and he just
played that you definitely don't want to
allow the Knight to come there I'm
looking at the clock which is very
important actually diac is ahead on a
clock and uh he's he's got 19 minutes
versus 15 for a report and um looks
looks very solid to me blocks position
here I think uh uh the ACT is absolutely
fine here thank you for that it's in the
game of mvl very very quickly I like
mbl's position uh he seems to be
enjoying a bit of Advantage but I really
I gotta go back to the honest Gary
dingler in game because uh ding Loren
played the very very human response uh
what you suggested now see he took on H3
and we considered this King G8 getting
on your running shoes you said it best
all black needs to do is teleport his
King to B8 and he's fine yeah there's a
big distance but between f8 and B8 and
after the move King G8 H4 and I gotta
say I really love anishi's Anish
position after this move H4 just keeps
all the tension got F5 on tap and pardon
me the Knight is coming to F5 it really
feels good
Bishop to D4 isn't that an invitation to
take crypto 4 it sure feels like it
right I mean I'm still stunned that
Wesley so didn't make that exchange
sacrifice when he had the opportunity to
let's have a look shall we Rook takes
Pawn tags again it's about this
coordination this Knight on F you know
we're exchanged now
but sometimes you just gotta ask your
yourself I'm material down but what are
my opponents pieces doing you took a
take a look at the Rook on G8 and Rook
on h8 and are they fearsome no they're
not frightening anybody you've got an
extra exchange good for you but look at
those Rooks they're ineffective and in
the meantime you might have five D six
did you see a defense because I didn't
I don't see a defense here okay one is
also coming and just white white can
still keep improving the position even
here down in exchange and I don't know
how Black's gonna get out of this this
is a beautiful beautiful game bar
because I mean this positional peace
sacrifice we we're familiar with it
everybody who's ever played E4 E5 uh
knows about these positional uh
sacrifices but this exchange sacrifice
looks really compelling uh yeah
definitely Anish is in a driver's seat
here he is winning here Rook takes D4 is
very tempting but it's not the very best
move here no it's not necessary to play
around in this position you still have
an advantage here and I will show the
key line after Rook D4 but the very best
move right now is Bishop B5 if he finds
this move Bishop B5 right now his
Advantage is like plus four here if he
just can play Four yes that's huge what
has Bishop B5 threaten yeah
Bishop B5 the knights are stuck yeah the
knights cannot move neither of the
nights now you can move in this position
and uh you you're down to some Rook
moves basically like Rook H5 which is
the very best for Rook G6 here and then
you're just simply trying to play the
move Knight F5 here the main thing what
you're trying to do here if you play the
move Knight F5 here immediately you run
into this tactic Bishop takes B2 and
your C4 Bishop is hanging exactly so by
putting the bishop on B5 you're avoiding
that and now now after Knight F5 we're
just going to capture in the black
position it's just simply collapsing
here he has to do something immediately
here that's why I like Rook H5 for
example he can try to do to try to maybe
sacrifice an exchange but here you have
a few different ways you can continue
Knight C4 is very strong
and that gives you the option also
Bishop D2 at some point or you can just
simply go for for a direct move F4 here
try to open up the f file against the
black king on f8 here Black's pieces are
all stock they make a very horrifying
impression the queen and Bishop looks so
good on B4 and D4 they do but besides
that terrible yes
the knights but by the way uh Rory I
appreciate what you're saying Bishop B5
is an outstanding excellent positional
move but uh I'm a carnivore you know
Rook takes D4 give me that guy Munch and
you take a knight F5 which is on the
board I didn't see a defense for ding
it's time to return the favor Yasser
Rook takes G5 now okay eliminating the
bishop very strong Bishop here and this
bishop has been a very very big problem
in this game sworn in Blacks position
for sure finally you need to get rid of
this bishop so pancakes and now you have
this move Knight E4 and
um thanks to Queen Tech C4 Queen takes
uh E4 yeah there is a queen C4 so and
now actually you have to find the only
move here
to have that big Advantage here still
and uh I think probably Anish will find
this it makes sense the move is Bishop
D3 here just move the bishop away and no
longer hang and attack the Knight on e4
yeah C5 walks into Maiden one yeah
Knight C5 Queen E7 so here the only move
to stay in the game is Knight C3 now
sacrificing the night
you capture and then D takes C3 there
are still some threats in this position
some Queen A3 ideas and the queen is the
best piece here covering the e7s we're
not allowing white to just win
immediately here you you're gonna have
to give up some pawns here it's not it's
not so easy
but let's jump into the Duda and mvl to
see what we have there what develops
seems like a repetition repetition is
going on as the players have gotten into
well Bishops of opposite color I said
mvl is for choice and that is still the
case and that unfortunately uh for him
these Bishops of opposite color
positions is not enough of an advantage
in it uh
and takes by the way uh for Duda these
Bishops endings have been a bit of a
curse he needs to be careful he needs to
be careful yes right like don't don't
blunder yes learn his lessons right yeah
it takes on E6 so yeah okay these PL
these players are heading towards I
think they're just gonna shake shake
shake hands momentarily no you think
there's going to be a handshake I think
they're gonna be I think they're gonna
play for another competition you know
like 20 moves right yeah they'll
probably improve their kings no uh and
we'll give up the pawn and
I think they'll find a way to repeat
yeah
okay
meanwhile uh Nepal did take on F3 and
furosha played Queen G4 immediately he
did play A6
Queen takes D3 and queen G4 yeah
farouza could be on the verge of a win
now Bishop C1 King D3 or King F2 Bishop
B2 there we go they found the repetition
the
foreign
[Music]
coming in today and Fabi also very aware
that Richie report was also a plus one
as he said it doesn't help my tournament
if Richie wins and uh that is definitely
the case so a draw agreed uh both of
these players coming in today looking
for a win a draw will not help their
campaigns let's jump to Ali Reza versus
nepo because help me out here
two losses for nepo one win right
yes and this
could be his third loss of the
tournament we are going to reach I think
an end game guys that I wanted to maybe
uh please show you that uh it looks like
white should be able to win but there's
going to be some technical technical
difficulties here a queen G4 move is
forced
uh the best response okay it takes back
HG Knight D6
now we play we care if we have two
options we can play Bishop B5 Bishop
Peter Bishop P5 is a more natural so
Pawn takes pawn bishop D6 this is the
best continuation for black so we have
this resulting end game here five pounds
per block uh three here for white here
and uh if we can win the B Pawn I think
it should be pretty straightforward win
here but I I don't think it's going to
be that easy to win the spawn
immediately Jan uh didn't exchange the
Queens he went Queen D5 he did play
Queen V5 and we had been looking at E4
this I think just loses if uh you know
now he's got E4 on the board yes this I
think with the Queens on the board I
think
so after Queen takes B5 firosho just
needs to make a move like Rook season I
guess I guess what Ian is trying to do
he's trying to keep the Queens on the
board to generate some chances firusha
is actually a little bit of uh time
travel here so Rook C2 I think Jan will
play Rook takes A6
F5 and then the play the move E5 whoa so
blockading the diagonal and stopping the
mate and
white white white is of course winning
here you can play you can play Queen G3
here putting pressure only five very
very nice Advantage there is even the
move F4 but probably I'm not going to
play that because it's weakening the
king here so
E4 so this is the current position five
minutes for uh alireza and uh 17 minutes
for Yan here with uh nine more nine more
moves to go right thank you for that uh
we do have a tweet I've been anxious to
see what uh uh whether or not we're
gonna get stumped by our uh audience and
love you
well I guess we're not going to get the
Tweet uh apologies
Russian help me out here from
from
Steph
he's like Joseph Smith
yeah something like that okay uh which
player has the best plane for win slash
for fun balance I would say Rapport does
his best not to get bored of any opening
that is true he is is one uh for for
throwing the patties that that is for
sure I think he answered his own
questions
but I think there are a lot of players
for me vessel and topolov was one of
those players that he didn't well I have
one yes please no go ahead I was about
to say he didn't mind losing even though
he minded losing he was one of those
players who were taking excessive risks
to try to win I mean he was much much
happier winning two and losing to than
making four draws I mean he really
really played hard and uh vesseline when
he was on top for him
watch out he's a force to be reckon with
who did you have in mind
he likes to play yeah yes he loves to
play he also tries a lot of fun openings
yeah throw throw those patties how about
you uh bar who who comes to mind when
you have the fun versus serious ratio uh
definitely a Vaseline I I remember him
playing a lot of sharp lines I see when
World Championship matches he played
lines where he sacrificed a couple of
Pawns and uh and of course reach a
report plays a lot of interesting
openings and we saw a little bit of that
from dingleren as well you know playing
uh unusual openings let's say in a world
championship matches from the from the
very top I think at the moment
definitely reach a report he tries a lot
of these different openings that
openings you don't think it's going to
work at a very high level
right
um and and let's just take a quick
reminder of the results thus far in this
round seven right we have two draws
between Duda and mvl right and Wesley
versus Carolina which was unfortunate
because that Wesley versus Bobby game
that was for first place
and it was a tough a draw at the office
so it kind of a little bit disappointed
good news for a few Russia since he's
about to catch up with the litter and
potentially good news for Rapport as
well as he's on the outside looking in
and Bishop A1 I think that was one of
the moves we were looking at Rook C2
Bishop C3 anything that maintains the
diagonal so that we can threaten to play
E4 takes F5 uh Bishop A1 is
is that move the precise move because it
wasn't high on your your list there of
our no it's not the best move here there
is there is an interesting idea now for
Jan to try to escape the best move was
to play Rook C2 and the advantage was
almost plus five in that position here
so let's take a look why Bishop A1 might
not be the best move here for alireza so
Queen A6 is one option okay give me the
Knight you take the Knight
and now a very unexpected Queen takes A1
uh oh Fortress so you take this alert
yep
Rook A1 check right King G2 right he
takes F5 Queen takes F5 and now we know
the Rook belongs on the E6 or G6 here
right
so we we can play Rook A6
so let's say you play Queen C8 check
King H7
take on B7 and
yeah this this end game is actually the
evaluation is surprisingly low I see you
see and there's a there's a possibility
that you're not going to be able to win
this position of course you still have
the H Pawn if you don't have the H Pawn
which has been completely equal but I
think there are some serious
difficulties in this position
to make progress here if I just King H2
Rook F6 right
how to make progress and try to advance
in this position let's say F3
and now G6
yeah I think I want to set my Rook up on
F5 and upon not nature 45 and just
shuffle my king to G8 into G7 yeah
so yeah this missed opportunity here and
I think Jan needs to find this move
Queen A6 another option he has is this
move H5 here okay I think it's gonna
result into the same kind of position
here so let's say queen G5
okay now you play the move Queen A6
it takes
it takes F5 again Queen A1 it's the same
idea just we have a pause on H5 and uh
it takes F5 and now
um you have a choice actually perhaps
you can take on H5 here yeah I think I
would take an H5 and thank you for the
opportunities of allowing this and if G6
we can come back and maybe create some
uh targets with the move H4 H5 so I
think this H5 move doesn't do that much
the best thing to do here is just to go
Queen A6 sacrifice the queen on A1 and
there are some good chances for a
fortress in that position for exactly uh
I asked my friend Jan Timon who has been
doing a great deal of work on studies I
said Young
what uh what has your work on studies
revealed to you what are some of the
most surprising things about the studies
and he said well yes sir one of the most
biggest surprises
is you put a black rook in this position
on the F6 Square
you take away the F7 Pawn you take away
the H6 Pawn you take away the B7 Pawn so
black has one Pawn on G7 a black Rook
that goes back and forth between F6 and
H6 and you put five white pawns on the
board five five
H5 H4 h3h I I think that's five or yeah
it could be H6 H5 H4 H3 H2 so white only
has H pawns and it's a dead draw even
though you have a rook and pawn versus
queen in let's say four pawns yes and
it's an easy draw so I'm thinking that
the chances of this Fortress holding are
much greater than the chances of farugia
winning which means the move Bishop A1
is a bad move
let's just send this uh Fortress in
Torres NK manual okay I'd love to pull
it up right now and check yeah just to
say okay check your memory if it's
working well that would be a huge Miss
for Ali Reza because a victory in our
defending Grand Chester Champion would
be tiger first let's just jump back to
the game of honest Gary and dingler in
because if Anish pulls this off it may
be one of his career defining moments
because it's it's been an extraordinary
game throughout when we left it we left
it here you you as you prescribe our uh
H Rook takes G uh five H6 G5 only move
Knight to E5 attacking the bishop
VAR just said drop back with the bishop
Advantage white we saw instead Bishop B5
Knight G4 King B1 and
anisha's prepping uh some kind of uh
maneuver whether it be cleaning floor
two minutes two minutes for how many
moves 11 moves
very very tough position there is one
difference guys when we were looking at
this position we were looking at the
move Knight E4 actually apparently we
were looking the position when so
instead of Knight E5 instead of 95 on
yes I apologize you're right yes the
best defense was 95 94 in this position
right here Bishop D3 is the only move
and Knight C3 white is probably still
almost winning but it's still not easy
but the way that dink played 95 Anish
played the best move Bishop B5 very
logical putting the bishop on a very
stable square and now you have a Knight
hanging and you need to try to defend it
and move you've got two knights yes no
King B1
F4 is desirable but Rook H2 there is
some Rook H2 idea here as well so the
question is what black can really do
here black has a few options you can
play the move D3 or you can play the
move Rook H2 here so let's start out
with Rook H2 okay again ding doesn't
have that much time so the best move
here is to play D6 sacrifice a pawn what
you're trying to achieve here is to open
up the C file for your rook and now you
do Rook C8 background mate Checkmate so
King G8 could be played and in this case
you have a move Bishop D3
and now again you have this Rook C8 idea
coming up and uh
looks like a winning Advantage here for
white Black's King is just so vulnerable
in this position G8
and I think Anish now is winning this
was not a very good move
and Anish can just win the game here
with a move Knight to H6 check
wow and then they're Head to Head uh
it's tight but it's
had a little bit of an advantage with
two more wins and he's about to have one
more maybe maybe one more 21 draws
that's a lot of draws between the two
but what is it about that move Knight H6
that is so compelling uh VAR because uh
you know I'm what can I say I'm looking
at that night on F5 and I'm just loving
it I just think that that it's just such
a great night I I wouldn't be
eager to necessarily trade it but it's
just that the resulting position sure
black king I can show what's happening
now you have to take Knight H6 on the
move and now Queen takes C5
and the Knight is hanging so your only
score is to go to his G4 and after this
move I actually can play even a move
like Queen F5
and Knight doesn't have squares to go to
so
and I have also G6 ideas I can also
simply just capture a pawn very
important part actually on C7 and now
the threat is to play Queen CA check and
pick up the Knight and now we have also
a very strong pass Pawn the main the
main problem here is also black doesn't
have any Contra play we've exchanged a
lot of the pieces and they're just
simply no control play here for uh block
you had me on Queen F5 and G6 Knight H6
check Knight takes H6 Queen takes E5 and
uh Knight G4 Queen F5 with the
introduction of G6 that's horrifying the
black king is just going to get
ransacked there
um wow and he played the Knight H6 as
you've prescribed it VAR
and
I can almost feel things uh pain I mean
the world champion is not supposed to be
get getting disabused you know uh no
that's not what happens to world
champions they're the ones usually
meeting out the punishment and showing
why they are world champions but this
move Knight H6
really is very very powerful
and Anisha needs to keep his composure
Queen takes E5
Knight G4 I I like grabbing pawns but
that little Queen F5 is just so strong
and for dingler in
terrible terrible tournament never saw
that coming he was actually my pick
to win the event I missed it by just a
smidge me too yes you do well misery
loves company thank you for joining me
VAR yeah I think one thing is clear dink
cannot wait this tournament to finish I
am every time I think he plays it's just
it's it's it seems It's like frustration
you know he's right he's not at his best
and uh
so he's definitely struggling now a lot
of these guys are not going to say you
know tiredness is a factor or anything
like that the world championship match I
remember very vividly an incredible
1978 World Championship Match in Baguio
City
Philippines between corchinoy and karpov
almost immediately after the tournament
ended Victor corchinoy jumped on
one of those Concord flights from Tokyo
to Rio in order to go to Buenos Aires to
play for the Swiss Olympic team like
almost from the time the opening the
closing ceremony did you do well oh he
destroyed the field I mean he's just
frightening and he was so mad you know
like from losing the championship the
funny part about that story is uh that
he goes from Tokyo to Rio and really
it's not a joke I mean he a lot he
arrives after an eight-hour flight Tokyo
Rio on Concord and it was an eight-hour
Delay from Rio to Buenos Aires it was
pretty funny you missed the the the
first few rounds of the Olympia uh
Knight H6 Queen takes E5 on the board
Knight G4 and here Anisha is just
enjoying the choices Queen takes C7 very
strong move as you've said does threaten
Queen C8 check picking up the night at
the same time you just gave yourself an
awesome I think everyone here should be
winning Queen F5 but that's that's
between G3 Queen E2 all of them should
be completely crushing but I I saw I saw
something with G6 and I just said oh
nothing else matters yeah that that's a
thud so Queen F5 and G6 uh on my next
turn and I think ding will throw in the
towel because his King is just again
about to be ransacked
um
and that's going to put an issue plus
one and he's only half a point behind
Fabiano and I think he still has to play
Fabiana right that's right tomorrow I
believe I mean Fabi actually is is is
facing all of his closest pursuers he
just played furuja Wesley yeah today
yeah but ferrugia uh yesterday yeah and
where Borussia was in second having won
two in a row
uh draw today he played Wesley who's
just a point Beyond draft and then yes
Anderson Robert left in the last two
rounds
all of his nearest pursuers he's for uh
Fabi if he's going to win this
tournament yeah well he's gonna he's
gonna do it the hard way uh by playing
all of his nearest competitors uh in the
championship rounds we don't have Queen
F5 on the board but uh at this moment it
seems like it's it's it's all one
one-way traffic uh if uh I I could ask
you uh what does the engines do well
they're obviously going to say whites
plus two ferruges queen versus The Rook
but
are they finding any way of breaking the
Fortress or are they just looping around
uh VAR
um I think the evaluation is actually
increased a little bit here and I think
perhaps maybe uh this move G6 played by
uh alireza in this position uh played by
nepo oh sorry a play by nepo here so the
question is if this G6 was necessary or
not because we saw uh black was also
looks like holding by just keeping the
Rook on the sixth rank on G6 and F6 but
he did play normal G6 and now Queen C8
King G7 and I think this H5 needs to be
played here because if you take here I
think after the move Rook A5 is
immediate draw because you can just go
Rook H5 Rook F5 right and I don't see
any way that you can try to improve your
king in this position very very
important to keep the pawn on H6 so
um so I think this would just simply be
a draw after Rook H5 Rook F5 so that's
why the move H5 I think needs to be
played here and is this really winning
uh let's see it's evaluation has
increased at least that's close to plus
five in this position plus ten wow with
the stronger engine so wow again once
again we see nepo again playing
quickly we have H5 on the board by the
way uh I was telling you about Jan Timon
studies and the idea of leaving
the pawn on G7 so that you could go Rook
F6 Rook H6 and it's like that pawn on G7
is actually key when we saw the move G6
a step in the wrong direction and after
H5 G5 now we see that there's
possibilities that The Rook could end up
getting into a zuke's Wong
like okay obviously I'm going to take
this Pawn right let's just make some
moves for a moment and let's just see
how I would try to achieve a zooks one
okay so we're here
and then the idea is what is Black's
next move you don't want to necessarily
play King H7 and allow Queen to f8 so
like maybe just Rook F6 rookie six right
except Rook F6 walks into this really
really egregious
Eternal pin
oops oops came over instantly right so
so F6 is a a mind Square you can't go to
F6 and if I go far let's say Rook a 6 6
will I lose the Rook on check
um some kind of checks indeed let's have
a look-see so I'll go check I have to go
to G8 you'll go to G8
okay
I mean white can just push the king to
G4 and maybe even to F5 I'm just
wondering which would be yeah Queen to
C4 this is how
it might be impossible to keep a
fortress by the way intriguingly to my
mind uh farouzia wasn't interested in
the pawn on B7 he played Queen C4
immediately helped me out there VAR I'm
a pond grubber how dare he
I think he's going to be able to take
this Pawn back soon anyway but uh don't
see why he didn't take on uh B7 let's
take a look uh he's going to be able to
take it just one or two moves later now
he can yeah he has Queen C3 check here
okay and uh you're gonna go King
G8
okay Queen CA check and pictures and
pick up the pawn here just we can go a
little bit deeper to see how actually
white is winning this position so let's
say Rook D6
and we put the queen on B2 first okay
and uh I think once you if you allow the
queen to achade I think that that
position is winning so right we need to
really look at the position where King
H7 H7 or King J let's say King H7 okay
but the problem now here is the queen
will get into a f8
ouch so we have to go King G yeah we
have to go King G8 here right
but now we lose to the move Queen B8
losing the ouch
no I think the Rook is on E6 in the game
uh VAR so maybe play King G8 yeah keep
the Rook defended yeah so King G3 King
G7 King G7
and now Queen B2 check
King G8 King G8
should the white king go to F5
well I was thinking if you go King G4
rookie for check my idea is if if I
managed to get my king on F5 then I
could sacrifice with Queen C8 Queen
takes E6 and pawn and the game should be
winning I was going to transfer my Rook
to F4 I was thinking that the Rook isn't
actually great on E6 so King G4 bar if
you wouldn't mind just kidding for Rook
check Rook check King F5 root check
King E5
and I put my Rook
on F4
I think good or bad uh it's it's it
looks like evaluation is increased so
this should be winning wow but again uh
let's see how exactly uh
so King h
let's say if King H7 okay ah now Queen
uh King D6
ouch
and now you covered the e-file first so
there is no checks on the file and
something like this as mentioned looks
like this yeah
go into a king and Pawn in game and
make a collection absolutely so yeah
looks like uh anniversa should be able
to win this position with the accurate
play here but it's a remarkable that he
played G6 because that pawn on G7 you
know could make all the difference in
the world so uh alireza going to win a
game that well it was winning drawing
winning maybe still never miss the
chance to create a great Fortress okay
uh Anish Gary ding Loren while we almost
over almost over but he didn't play the
move Queen F5 he he yeah he's a he's a
gold carrying member of the pond
grubbers Society he played Queen takes
E7 with the threat of Queen C8 and give
me the Knight ding got out of that
threat uh with the move King G7 but then
walked into G6 Rook f8 takes and we can
just see that there's a lot of suffering
going on here maybe the suffering is
actually going to be over right away
once you notice that there's a move
Queen
C3 check
is one line as well as Queen G3 is the
other simple alternative both Queen C3
check
and again this it's all about this
Knight being in a pin and I think that's
it I think yeah I think we'll see and
there's a handshake being resigned and
our nation plus one now wow
I mean seriously guys I I sometimes you
just gotta tip your hat and say to Anish
you know when you do your best game
collection
this game is you know chapter one you
know defeating the new world champion
convincingly a beautiful positional
Sacrifice from start to finish uh Anish
was in the driver's seat he was
dictating from move 12 or something
maybe a few chances for ding to equalize
but uh now he's a half a point behind
and suddenly you know and he's playing
the leader tomorrow right the sun is
shining the birds are are chirping uh
everything's going uh well and our
results so far right we started this
very important Victory with a quick draw
between Wesley so and Fabiano caruana
right then a second draw between Duda
and MBL and just now we had a win by
Gary against ding
bringing Anish to plus one a half a
point behind our tournament leader
Carolina but Bobby may have company as
alireza our defending grantchester
Champion he's putting together a very
nice game and you're expecting that he
will take down nepo as the two players
there uh ding now Richard is not out of
it
excuse me Richard is not out of it
either he's at plus one hey guys uh some
room at the top can you guys uh he's
playing against dioc and we've we've
kind of felt that the position has been
balanced for some time he set up that
line that you mentioned uh VAR with
Queen G5 but you said that black could
meet this
with Queen f8 which is exactly what has
happened by the way let me make sure
that the players aren't repeating the
position a bit they haven't I think they
just reach the move 40 so right Richie
will try to come up with some ideas to
change up the position
because they've been in this position
for last like 30 moves things are right
they did somehow there was a black
Bishop on D6 that did trade itself off
for a white night uh VAR still looks
very balanced but maybe maybe slightly
better for white I'm not sure though
because this Pawn on C3 is so weak and
you mentioned Rook C4 and Rook takes D4
as a type of possibility that white
doesn't want to suffer
yeah not much progress has been made
here I wouldn't be surprised if we see
some type of repetition here between G5
Queen E7 and they've just been
maneuvering Richie tried to bring the
Knight on D3 but there was not much luck
there because you can't really go to E5
and uh now they've you know he's trying
to create some chances but it's Queen f8
is just very solid here
um
yeah and it looks like this game is
probably going to be a draw here but
firusha played that move Queen C3 check
and he's gonna pick up the pawn against
Yan and uh I think that end game is lost
I think Jan uh definitely misstep you
know with the smooth G6 right uh
changing the structure in this kind of
positions where you think you have a
fortress it's very important especially
in end games you have to be very careful
moving these pawns and uh now King uh H7
Queen C7 will be played
first you have to eliminate that Palm
before black plays the move B6 it could
be yeah on remains on the board it's not
going to be that easy exactly so it's
important to pick up the pawn and I
think with activating the king he should
be able to win this position so what a
day if uh the world champion and the
Challenger go down today yeah again so I
mean as we we came in uh today's
broadcast and we did the standings and
I'm looking at a tie for the seventh
eight and Ninth position which featured
Challenger and Champion tied from
seventh eighth and Ninth now I think if
nepo loses eighth and Ninth are reserved
exclusively for the champion and
Challenger really really really shocking
to see two of the greatest players of
the world uh suffering in the lower half
of the field goes to show grantchester
can't take anything for granted these
guys are so good and we do expect that
the queen will
queen of three okay I was about to say
queen C7 picks upon Queen F3 the old
double attack
does the same and
um I think maybe the move Queen F3 is
actually more precise if I do play the
move Queen C7 maybe I'm giving my
opponent an opportunity
to put his Rook on F4 when my king isn't
already on E5 and I may regret that so
uh Ali raises move Queen F3 just stops
you from playing Rook F6 and if you do
play King G7 don't think you're gonna go
Rook F6 in these positions either
because oops and here we go back to that
question we had which is more important
openings or end games right and even on
this level today you can see if nepo
remembered that he can set up a fortress
with the pawn on G7 on G7 right save
this game so imagine that you know you
played this perfect openings and you got
everything and then it led to a position
where you have a draw
and because you don't know the endings
and you end up playing the move G7 G6
and G6 G5 you lose and on the other hand
firoza knew when to immediately play H5
in the right moment exactly so it it's
kind of strange but you know if I could
play for example as black here King G8
Queen takes uh and then the illegal move
uh G
5 G7 my chances of holding a fortress
just go increase exponentially again if
the pawn was on G7 I would put the Rook
on F6 and I would just be moving my king
back and forth and saying to my opponent
how are you going to improve your king
how are you going to improve your queen
and that move G6
Rue the day as uh we're expecting two
victories
and let's jump to Bucharest as Christian
is with our latest winner
we are here with Anish after a brilliant
Victory against the world champion uh
dingly ran Anish you came you're smiling
you're quite happy right now tell us a
bit about your feelings I'm of course
very happy to repeat world champion this
year I've beaten
overall champion
you could say Thrice maybe I mean it's
hard to say because I beat Magnus when
he was a champion then I'd be ding when
he before he was watching but now I beat
him again so I'm really happy with with
that and but as you mentioned before we
started the interview we were just
taking advantage of the tired of the
tired world champion tell us a bit about
how you took advantage of the energy
levels you started off with this idea
yeah I think I think
um I remembered that this move order is
not very good because I can suck yeah
because I think the sack here is strong
in many cases the sack is okay for black
but in this case I think it was strong
but here perhaps maybe he can start with
G5 before yeah obviously yes for example
I mean amongst many things you can do is
you can start with but of course here I
mean you have to reckon is the thing
yeah so it's not so obvious but in
general like there are so many photos
it's just I was fortunate that I looked
at this there was a one hilarious idea
in here that you go King Italy you see
this one is very nice this is what Fabi
was mentioning do you think that you
know it before no no no he was just
wondering what yeah the noise after
Bishop takes no no this is I
positioned in my prep with slightly
different version I knew this idea but
here yeah I was not um sure I think I
should have gone through F1 in Knight F5
uh later I realized that because I I
didn't see what he wants to do
um but I felt that this was soft yeah
maybe uh
because okay you know the idea of
location is a very interesting now he
wants to set up the bishop of two tricks
let's say G4 equals Bishop if I go
Knight G3 there's actually a very
beautiful um a beautiful idea I thought
Nigeria is very bad because of King G6
okay I didn't see Knight F5 I thought
the H1 was very nice now Bishop G4
Bishop F6 Queen to seven this is the
systematic trick yeah I didn't want to
fall forward yeah 93 Bishop E3 Fe is um
is sort of a thing
in this position so I was kind of going
for this
um and after queen of seven I just got a
little confused um I didn't see how to
how to break through somehow because I
was calculating the stuff with the Rook
of one Knight B8 Knight F5 takes takes
Knight D7 F4 I guess I think ef4 even I
was not sure and it was a little vague
all
um I didn't see how I'm winning four
yes and it's not obvious I said 25
compared to skin G2 I didn't quite see
the of this like I thought he might
Escape here so I thought not a long
Castle I thought it was strong because
98th idea was to go D4 yeah and this I
was not sure actually I was actually
expecting this
I think I saw
um
I thought I think I saw I have a
reputation
at least I'm wondering why not quinjet
reversed
95 Bishop F6 though
ah this is an illusion Queen H no yeah
yeah this is an illusion okay okay
ah yeah yeah he has another knife I
think okay so I need first I need to
First include Bishop D5 okay C6 and now
do this
and now I can take only seven and take
only six in the D6 bonus where it is
falling okay like that yeah I mean I
frankly
well I was not sure actually he was
probably okay after this whole thing
it's probably a draw I I was it was very
vague to me ruke I was very confused to
play very fast not easy right no no and
also I mean it's just like super unclear
uh I mean I knew Knight F1 Bishop of two
I did like to be honest that was more or
less so all about this position it was
not even this position it was frankly
another one which was very similar so I
had to like figure out on my own and I
was far from sure if I'm following the
right path it was all a little vague I
mean 95 95 without the engine screaming
you know I have my very nice setup you
know in my room I have like a bunch of
engines they're super deep and I'm
sitting there and it's all clear 95 95
and it all looks great then you come to
the board and you are a totally idiot
there have not not forget you just have
no idea like you look at the same 95.95
and you don't know which one on your
powerful engine is plus two which one is
-050 if you know which one is and it
looks all very different but it's also
one of those positions that you don't
take seriously as much because you see
plus two and then you continue a little
bit but then you're like okay yeah and
of course I mean you cannot if you're
gonna check every plus two in this kind
of openings I mean you need to prepare a
lot of months and there are so many
blasters so so of course I didn't I
shouldn't have checked it I'm just
saying that it was not easy to play yeah
because I was happy I thought
she allows 94 he I saw his class before
I thought his toast
but it was very unclear I realized after
he played it I seen a computer says
Knight to five I didn't really see the
point after this in 97 I thought he's
escaping now
okay I mean computer says yeah you can
just do it slowly okay but that's a D4
the whole point of going long Castle was
that I have not been before yeah and in
DCd I thought Knight C6 maybe and I was
calculating this line actually I thought
at some point maybe he's all right I
think Rook D4 but then I point closer
inspection I realized I am better so I
can take take Knight G4
ah before I thought your Cafe I thought
actually he might hold this I didn't see
foreign
this was what I thought and I thought
that actually he might hold
yeah but at this point I was not like I
was not sure I realized I was not too
sure maybe I was never winning I don't
know I was just sort of going with the
flow and I was happy at least here was a
key moment of the queen before I have
quinito because kimbi won
um my original intention would be
a mistake for a different reason than I
thought although I saw this I saw this
actually that this is probably a drum
this um this thing yeah it's a beautiful
perpetual
and can you for check I saw this one
yeah I also thought uh besides this I
also thought Bishop D4 was okay D4 ed4
DFE
but yeah I mean okay it of course he was
very obvious but I thought it was okay
but it's actually not yeah I mean we
should you have to take take night yeah
I mean I'm down in exchange but um this
king is yeah yeah I missed 94. I thought
you know the structure the stuff is
hanging here so I missed this um but
even this is not
anyway was the key anyway yeah yeah and
I saw this this was another move I have
and I thought can be one is better but
then I realized actually that Queenie 2
is the move yeah and that's where I felt
um like here I felt that things are
turning my way now I was certain I'm
better and he tried I'm not sure if I
for us it almost felt like this was the
critical role yeah
practically he's the one having a much
more yeah
which was good but I thought Bishop
before yeah here okay the hands took
maybe I shouldn't have but I thought you
know if Rook D4 is indeed winning and
I'm not gonna do it like you know then
I'm the I'm the bad guy you know you
have to sacrifice the room yeah okay and
here he he is completely lost yeah it's
nice because he um after the game he
tried to catch two he felt very bad for
him but we didn't see actually the exact
win here of the king Jade
but it is uh Bishop to D3 taking away
this H7 Square very important
yes I hope I would have found this
basically the point here is that my king
is super safe Bishop on B5 is nice
because there is no Perpetual mechanism
anymore yeah and his King on a fight is
slow slow burning than nothing G at 96
yards
all over so I think I was quite lucky
um somewhere around here normally he
would calculate uh these things better
better than me but um
taking advantage of title Champion I
reach plus one going into the
championship round still have a point
behind the leader or the leaders
depending on what alireza is going to do
tomorrow you're playing one of them
Fabiano with the black pieces how are
you going to strategize that matchup
well nowadays it's very difficult
um
also for players playing whites
because you know against one E4 uh you
know I can play the Berlin I can play
the night I can also play the French as
it's very trendy now yes but the problem
for the black players is that nobody
knows um also what first move uh why two
places hard to strategize but I think
more than the tournament score I'm just
happy that I won a game because it's
been a while and it's very hard to win a
game in a top tournament
into a classical tournament because
everybody is very well prepared
defending very well and um
there are many ways in which you can not
win the game first of all you might get
worse secondly you might have equality
and not have any chances third you might
get a chance but not utilize it fourth
you might be winning but you might ruin
it Fifth you might be completely winning
and you might still ruin it so how many
of those did you have in this tournament
yeah in my in my career I've had plenty
but in this tournament so far I didn't
have any chances on very small ones like
very fleeting ones like against others I
had the one move when I was a bit better
and I uh misassed that moment and then I
was no better no better anymore so I'm
just happy that I won today's game I
think the standing is early to count the
hands I play Still wonderful players uh
every day here is you're treated you
know to either a world champion or a
challenger or an ex Challenger and I
have still Fabiano who is a legend and
uh you're not playing contemporary
Legends of our Sports every day and this
is really beautiful and in general I
think this tournament is it's quite
wonderful because it is
you sort of play this generation of
um of Legends around born around 1990
and there are no youngsters nor is there
Magnus it's okay address doesn't count
he's too high rated to be youngster so
it is sort of an interesting mix pure
event well the opposite there's no mix
it's like one generation is present here
uh it's actually very interesting
alireza is kind of like the news yeah
accept him because he's very high rated
we'll accept him in but I mean you know
usually you've got to go cash abusator
he's an elder all right you guys yeah
yeah also he's you know so it's um
too cocky to be young sir
speaking of what he Reza Anisha and
you're a great commentator and you
actually made some interesting points
tell us a bit about this engine yeah
it's fascinating this one as far as I
remember but I was thinking about it so
as far as I remember this should be lost
for black and I even think okay just for
argument sake I even think
um
I thought this was lost because I
remembered that the wisdom is if you've
got the pawn H6
you don't have Rook h636 most so the
wisdom is that you should not have that
pawn on H6 but I was a red ski yes yes
but then I was wondering while we were
talking I was wondering about
might be at sukswang something like that
this is the Tukes one but then I was
wondering how that's why it went after
this because
check yeah
um but I see that okay we need table
bases and then what
maybe yeah we get
yeah anyway I was suddenly wondering
about it but as far as I remember maybe
I mixed up with something very similar
but as far as I remember the knowledge
is that with the pawn H6
um no I think you're correct about that
like especially with the pawn H6 is win
for white and without the black ball on
H6 is a draw which is insanely
counterintuitive it's like incredible um
because and the point is that you've got
Rook H6 Rook um E6 well I think the
thing about the game I think it's even
easier because there is no more
distillate ideas the extra F Pawn it's
just nice to have and I think when you
eventually
we need to do it so let's say you go
King file yeah then look F5 we need to
do it accurate maybe here here and then
here I think once you get this rookie 6
maybe F3
we I think this is sort of the song we
have and now King H7 Queen f8 is um
winning on the spot
and you don't even have Rook F6 no no
and in general it's nicer to have a pair
of phones on the board just for the
winning side it's always better to have
a pair more
so I think this is a win and the idea is
that if you make a random move here is
going to be some bad news happening to
you I don't know what it is but
something bad should happen to you
oh also also you know what's problem
Christian another problem we have here
and the problem we have is that
if you go rookie six Queen takes this
yeah that's another problem that she
wouldn't have without the gnf once yeah
[Music]
I am curious was the mix-up as early as
not so much not so much yeah it was all
right yeah no no he was fine oh he was
equalized okay
just giving up the pawn was probably not
that was actually cool though but he
should have broken 96 but it's a bit
counterintuitive yeah actually it was uh
he played pretty well with in the
opening year with black but of course
when you sacrifice spawn for activity
you you gotta have it all straightened
out yeah not easy Anish thank you very
much for joining us and giving your
insights thank you guys back to you
thank you Anish and Christian I think
Anish is taking over our job
let's take a look at anisha's road ahead
thanks to his victory he's pulled
himself right up there on the podium uh
wow yes uh he has a date yeah he's in
fast one and tomorrow he has the
tournament Soul Leader Fabiano Carolina
I like like he said he's playing 2x
World Championship Challengers
absolutely so every every day is a
challenge as you will get nepo in the
final round and what about Bobby's room
uh road ahead he's going to be playing
obviously on a niche tomorrow but then
the last round another person who is
trying to catch him Robert exactly
Richie at the moment three and a half
points imagine that Richie was to win a
game against dioc which we think is
going to be a draw uh frankly but if he
were to win I mean uh Bobby's playing
all of his very nearest
pursuers uh interesting uh what
what Anish was saying about the H6 pawn
and uh the fact that it's actually
a pain that this Pawn is on H6 and
really if that G5 Pawn had remained on
the G7 Square as nepo should have left
it there his G6 really was an a terrible
step in the wrong direction we think
that this game is over uh winning I I
mean to say for
um
let's again check in on the Richie game
um some bad blood early but between the
two players as I think that they weren't
happy with one just a misunderstanding I
think so too uh Richie was not ready to
acquiesce to the draw he did not play
Queen E5 inviting Queen E7 Queen H6 he
played the McQueen E3 Queen D6 Rook B3
um
Richie's looking for an opportunity of
bringing the Rook on B3 which just
frankly is playing a defensive role to a
better Square VAR what on Earth is the
better Square
well he just put it on C1 just trying to
defend but I think it's better placed on
Syrian because at some point if the
position opens up he can be able to put
it on F1 for example if if he plays G4
at some point it's I think definitely
better than on B3 yeah because we have
felt a little bit in no man's land let's
see some of the key lines in this
position still I think position is
balanced so
for example you can just defend with
this move okay C7 just to see okay what
is your next move what is White gonna do
here you can't really move the queen
again we see engine wants to do some
repetition maybe Queen f8 again you
never want to trade coins because after
you trade Queens you can only be worse
now come back to D2 perhaps and black
again plays the move Queen D6 here but
the more you're looking I mean I gotta
pledge from from the starting position
you play the move Rook C7 let's get some
action let's go G4
I mean in this case maybe my Rooks can
swing to the open f file if you would
oblige me yeah the problem now Yasser is
to move F4 actually you're a party
pooper dude open up the position for me
yeah well blocking the diagonal and now
you have to play Queen D2 okay and uh
now we can even play the move cheese H6
here white snide is and the question is
how is this Knight gonna come back into
the game here you don't have any scores
really you can go to if you can go to F6
but then it has to come right back you
know I thought I was being clever by
inducing the move F5 F4 but you're
absolutely right now see my knight on H5
is left high and dry taking on G4 guys
will be a critical mistake after that
white is looking great here you can
write an f file to attack so that
definitely I We're not gonna see the
move F takes G4 F4 is the right way to
go and uh it's still it's still equal
after but the Knight is on H5 sort of
Trapped in that position true true but
from Richie's point of view I mean if he
could win this game
get a tie for first and uh he would have
Destiny in his grasp as well and he's
playing a player let's be frank who
hasn't played at least
from the tournament perspective so far
successfully right but today he hasn't
made made any mistakes so Daniel has
played decent trying to get like an
usual saying it's very hard to get a win
and at this level yeah any any wins a
good win
um is time a factor in these two no
because they recently made move 40 they
still both have more than 20 minutes on
the clock so somebody had a serious
conversation with Daniel and said look
your first five games were atrocious you
were getting the time trouble each and
every game and then you were blundering
you can't do that and ever since that
free day
Daniel's uh been doing his very best to
to maintain the the clocks
but we've got a treat coming up what is
this one oh
that line score is just really I mean
for anybody it's bad but for a world
champion guys tournament yes yes
I didn't see that coming because again I
just uh I think Daniel's realized that
world championship match just took a lot
yes I was expecting just nine draws that
he would be so tired that he would just
make a lot of draws okay but Richie
conversely seems inspired by the world
championship match he wasn't uh at the
board yeah and he's doing very very well
and we're just looking at the game
between uh ding uh Laren and farrugia
um
yeah I got David living on my mind out
um VAR
Christian
and Anish were looking at ways of
breaking the Fortress have you come up
with a very concrete way of doing
precisely that breaking Black's Fortress
I I think so it's it's not immediate but
uh there is a plan I will show you but
before we do that I want to show you one
idea that I think is critical for this
end game and perhaps maybe Jan missed
this if we go back a little bit to this
position here uh where he it seems like
he had a chance in at some point to put
the Rook uh on F4 and if you can do that
then you're going to be very happy
because uh your if your Rook is on F4
you just go Rook H4 Rook F4 is it looks
like it's going to be a fortress yeah
but there is a problem with this mode
let's say it starts out with this move
Queen B8 I can't play King GC yeah King
G7 always loses right always loses to
the move uh Queen E5 right so you're
gonna be in a pin and you will lose the
game so you have to play King H7 right
then you play the move King G3 play Rook
F4 yeah let's say you play the move Rook
F4 and it seems like you're you're
holding a rook H4 but the problem is now
you're losing the king and pawn end game
after Queen takes a four
this is perhaps what he missed that this
is just completely hopeless here because
King G7
King F5 I have a lot of reserved moves
here with this F Pawn so if you go King
GA King F6 King f8 now you play F4 and
if you go to King G8 or King ghee it
doesn't matter I go the other opposite
direction and after F5 this is a lost
King and pawn end game so it's possible
that he maybe missed this idea when he
allowed the smooth H4 H5 right but the
current position now if we go back
so King F5 alireza is playing all the
best moves here and at some point if you
allow the queen takes E6 that King and
pawn end game is also lost right so with
this H5 H6 spawns a lot of this King and
pawning games are simply lost because
white in king is too active here so if
you try to hang on on the sixth round I
was trying to do that to try to make
sure the kick doesn't cross so let's say
he plays
Rook A6 here
in this position now you have ideas like
this queen C5
and now if you play the move Rook E6
you're losing to the move Queen CA check
King G7 and
Queen takes C6 and winning King and pawn
end game after G4 you don't even have to
go after this Pawn you can actually try
to win the H6 pawn and then return G5
pick up the G4 Pawn so
the current position we have Rook A6 now
and yeah Queen C5
I really like this move and
stopping Rook A5 check yeah let's say we
play King G7 a king G7 then Queen C3
check
can go to the background because of the
queen C8 thread so the only move is King
H7 right and now very strong move Queen
CA So eventually what happens you get
this position and Rook A5 is going to
run into the king F6 you don't have the
rookie 6 option because of the queen E6
so you have only uh Rook B6 left and now
it's coming you have this move Queen C7
attacking the rook and the on left sense
so it looks like white is just gonna win
the game and there is no really a way to
hold this for you thank you uh Vara I
remember playing in a tournament in The
Hague in Holland it was aegon it was Man
versus machine and the international
Master Roberto Fuentes was up against
the computer and he was in a rook and
pan and game a pawn down and I was
watching the game and Roberto played the
move I thought he should play and the
operator of the machine said to him I'm
sorry Mr sofuentes his Checkmate in 47.
we both very like check later for it I
said Roberto don't believe him play on
and there's no way this was made at 47.
actually I've been told the current
positions like made in 20 yeah
the the computers now see a very very
clear uh way of breaking the Fortress
and for wow farrugia
uh what a turnaround uh I mean starting
with a loss starting with a loss against
Wesley so and he's he's 1-3 but he was
seriously worse against Fabi so he's
been handing a roller coaster ride so
far but yes about to be three about to
be three and again uh if you say to me
it's made in 20 I I trust that uh he
will find the mate King
is that right no Queen C4 yeah sorry I
mean okay five check is nothing to be
afraid of because the contrary King F6
is welcome yes and
away we go and by the way that looks
like a
doesn't that accelerate everything that
you were talking about Queen C4 attacks
The Rook as we've been talking uh these
King upon in games are just dead I guess
black can play Rook P6
and then after Rook B6 then you can play
Queen C5 and it's still the
same position yes uh can't I get my
queen uh somehow to the magic F5 f8
Square
yeah like uh oops no it's definitely
over very soon right right uh looks
looks very very very good which again
Remy means that Richie is on the outside
looking in he needs a win to tie with
Fabi and
quite likely alireza as well not much
has happened but we just saw the move
Rook B8 which is a kind of a confounding
move I won't even try to express showing
that he can just stand still well white
can't break through that's exactly what
I think dayaka say I'm just going to
keep the position uh I won't hang or
blunder anything I'm going to play Rook
uh B8 go ahead and do your worse
um question VAR is can white do
something like really really silly gain
some space on the on the king side play
H4 let me just show you I mean I don't
even know if if putting the pawns up the
board is the right idea but for the
moment
I've got a great plan
here it comes ready hold hold your
breath I'm gonna ruin your plans again
with F4 you're never gonna let me open
and I was wondering with the pawn on H4
can I play for G5 and Knight F6 arguably
if Richard was in masculine situation
that's what I'm saying right like maybe
try this you know it's uh Victory or
bust you go you you you go all out
anything to be suggested for advancing
H4 and slowly hoping hoping to gain more
space or let's take a look that's one
thing with that plan I'm a little bit
worried about maybe a possible E5 break
that block can do when the king is on H3
here but let's check that line here you
said that you were suggesting so uh if
H4 let's say he's he's waiting right
King G2
uh we wait a little bit more right and
you play the move you finally play the
move G4 sure
this is the most active plan I can find
it's playing for G4 and I know you're
not going to open up the f file and be a
nice person actually here actually I can
already because the king is misplaced on
H3 because a lot of this lines now I
have Rook C3 and your king is going to
be pinned so now actually capture
capture and E5 is very strong and looks
like he has their black is taking over
the game here yeah
it's it's not uh very well by the way
yeah they're repeating guys so we might
see a handshake
right well I mean for Richie it will
mean he maintains a rather not a rather
lofty plus one
but with the white pieces maybe he was
hoping for a little bit a little bit
more yeah his opinion choice would tell
us that he was hoping to get a game yes
he was with this uh
just when you thought it was safe it
tricked you to uh
to
agree to a draw
we've got Rook to oops sorry let me just
refresh does it come with any follow-up
idea
well just that the Rook was better on
deep that The Rook is better on D3 than
it was on B3 uh
Rook to D3
um
again does it
is there something behind what's the
active idea for white for Richie with
his Rook on D3 so dioc plays the same
thing he just waits he goes Rook C4 to
C7 and back and forth what's the idea of
Rook D3 bar yeah you can play Rook C7
you also have to move Rook A4 yes sir
you don't have to just uh sit passively
you can play Rook A4 which is actually
the best move here but just in case
let's just play this move just see if
block stays again what is a plan again
we see a suggestion to get the queen on
H6 which we know is already going to be
met by Queen f8 and that doesn't do much
Queen G5 is the same thing will be met
by Queen E7 right and uh no concrete
plan I don't see any Palm breaks again
if you play G4 this will be met by F4
right and again the ninth is going to be
misplaced on H5 here I don't see any any
plan here for Richie to try to play for
a win because if he tries to
uh maybe you can move this Rook at the
moment but again I don't see uh an idea
let's say it's row here too he can play
Rook C2 but that will be met by Rook C4
so I don't think he can really do much
in this position
um it's he has to take a lot of risks
and I think it can really backfire if he
does that I I can well imagine that Rook
a for uh going active is actually the
best move because it suddenly come up
with some
really great stuff imagine this Rook D3
and we're just going to go back and
forth for black right we're going to let
me have my fun if you will after Rook
back I'm going to go H3
You're Gonna Go Roxy for yay okay I'm
gonna go F4 no I'm going to play G4 and
come hell or high water I'm gonna Force
upon trade you're gonna oblige Me by
going back and I'll play G4 now you
can't play F4 because I'm occupied the
square how you like them apples
you're not afraid of it after you get
over your hilarity as you stop laughing
what
uh let's say I take on G4 yeah possibly
go Queenie seven Queen H4 maybe Queen E7
and queen H4 maybe okay
um
yes precisely I was hoping that my
knight would end up on the F6 square and
I would swing a major piece to the H
file whether it be okay
well I mean uh they tell me that's the
the goal
yeah
that is the goal so yeah it's slow it's
very very slow but when I put by the way
when I play the move F4 I'm Burning
Bridges
in the sense that the Knight on H5 isn't
coming back it's going to go to F6 one
day or it's going to be terrible it's
just going to be stuck on H5 so I play a
move like F4
but I did it with the deliberate
intention of course of one day uh
getting something on the hvl by the way
we have Richie
Richie did play Just Rook E1 I don't
know if that changes anything but we
believe that alireza is about to put the
finishing touches
very very very important uh win yes
let's take a look Queen C7 basically
Runs The Rook out of squares right yeah
forcing it to go or queen C5 guys both
all Queen C5 sorry same thing yeah you
can't sorry in my Minds I I I I I I
wanted to control that there is Queen C8
check the same on rookie six exactly
check so no Rook A6 No rookie six so if
I go down I see a check Queen C8 or even
King yeah King F6 right away even better
uh brutal okay so we might be seeing
after the move Queen C5
just domination of Queen Over The Rook a
handshake
I think so we don't have any moves we
don't have an answer to Queen C5
and he's about to make his yeah
move Queen C5
that was brilliant what he found earlier
with A5 A6 yeah that won the game it did
and from Napo uh just a calculation
error because when he was taking on F3
I'm sure he had it in his mind that he
had B7 protected just didn't understand
cringe before yeah uh how powerful the
more Queen G4 was
by the way did that ever make an
impression on you did you ever have that
as a conscious thought
um
in
Paul cares
the last tournament he ever played in
was in Vancouver BC just a stone's throw
away from Seattle Washington I was a
student at the time so I couldn't play
in the Vancouver open but I could visit
I went up to visit the tournament and
Paul carrez
I was just eyeballing him like just like
a hawk like every move he made you know
and I watched how he moved the pieces
uh he he he grasped a piece firmly
he held it for a half second moved it to
the square
made sure that the piece was really
center of the square
he released the piece made sure that it
was on the right square and gently
pressed the clock and I was so impressed
by his movement of the Priestess the
grace with which he moved the pieces I
went home to emulate him even though I
couldn't make the moves of Paul korres I
wanted to be able to play the way with
the grace did you ever have that as a
conscious thought that I want to move
the pieces gracefully not flip-flopping
and blah blah blah blah and putting them
precisely in the middle of the board you
know I have literally never thought
about that in my life
wow
wow wow what can I say VAR I I'm
rethinking maybe I've done something
wrong maybe I wasn't moving my paper how
about you do you like playing with a
precise
graceful move is that something that you
consciously yes try absolutely I don't I
want to make sure all my pieces are in
middle of the squares that's the first
thing I do when I sit down I just make
sure all the piece on a perfectly lined
up and when I put the moves in just make
sure they're in the in the center of the
square so that's a thing that I've never
heard about well now you know I mean
yeah uh by the way more I mean somehow
uh nepo we thought that uh
nepo's Rook wasn't going to make it the
F4 square that quite frankly uh he
missed an opportunity to do that he has
got his Rook there but the king is
coming to f8 and maybe yeah maybe the
Checkmate uh oh uh so
um The Rook on F3
too little too late
yes now it's actually right now he can
just play Queen C8 check and if King G7
Queen f8 check and to Simply take on F7
that's the same that's what he is going
to do and if you don't play King G7 you
play King H7 then you have the option to
play King f8 and then you're threaten
Queen C3 and mate on G7 so I think
resignation that's nice is coming right
now King H7 King comes to f8 G6 is
protected G7 is not protected you're
ready to play a queen to the dark square
and make Checkmate here nepo is inviting
Queen fa check and queen takes F7 and
I'm sure he's intending resignation the
moment uh
farusha plays Queen takes F7
yeah what a fantastic game by ferocia
seriously I think Anish giri has played
really a career defining game today it
was just a marvelous marvelous game I
don't care the fact even these world
champions whether they're tired wounded
I don't care a victory over the world
champion is something to be relished and
a victory over nepo equally something to
be relished Queen F7 and I think that's
it
bravo bravo
I'm gonna guess he's talking about that
pawn G6 move right now yeah yeah
frustrating to play the G6 and lose like
this
now see you said it best uh champion and
Challenger both losing in the same round
and boy did that shake up our standings
and uh here's our road ahead for one of
our tournament co-leaders right feroza
has Duda and mvl left in the last round
I would say an easier road ahead than
Fabi who is going to be playing Anish
Geary tomorrow as well as Richard
Rapport and the championship round and
uh we have one game remaining
and we are tied at the top
I think we're going to be ready for a
break in the in the not too distance
future and as we get ready for the break
I just want to again shout out to our
audience we do enjoy your quizzes and
questions so uh get those prepared and
uh VAR I mean I know it's not you know
final thoughts or anything like that but
this is a stunning round the champion
and Challenger to the very very best
players in the world going down in the
same round absolutely it just shows how
much energy it took to play the world
championship match and if these players
are fresh and they're normal for they
will definitely perform much much better
you can still have like a bad tournament
but both of them are on
-2 right now so this is something we
couldn't expect
so definitely they will probably take
some break and try to come back stronger
in the uh the rest of the GCT events
yeah yeah I mean minus 2 as we get
Perugia miked up in Bucharest I see once
again the game between
diac and Richard back and forth
repetition well again you know there was
there was a certainly opportunity for
Richard to do that we did Sue by the way
Queen A3 Queen back to d8 uh I'm a
little bit surprised we didn't see the
move Rook A4 uh intimating that hey you
know like maybe I'm gonna go after your
Pawn I'm gonna you know it takes me a
long time to win the pawn but what he
got
uh he didn't play that and Richie's just
put Rook F1 on the board again we are
getting ready for uh Ali Reza to join
yeah she's clearly not afraid of
whatever might be on the king side at 4G
yeah he is ready to meet Queen H6 at any
moment with the move Queen f8 and uh
Richie is probably okay I can make a
draw I can play the move Rook C1 just
defending the pawn on C3 times not a
particular Factor but
you know unless it's G4 I mean that's
the only active move right unless you
know like the fact that your Queen's not
here imagine I played an idiot I'm an
idiot I I played the move G4 let's see
if I can uh pardon me this one drops
Pawn on C3 truly but I was saying I was
thinking rather that when your Queen's
not on D6 F4 I might take the pawn right
if you take my Pawn on C3 in this
particular case I don't think you wanted
to allow this right I mean it takes D4
Knight F6 no no I'm still takes D4
that's beautiful that just defends all
my threats but sorry I missed that but
wait after G5 Knight F6 come okay
but we have firusha ready for the
interview with Christian all right
thanks guys alireza first of all
congratulations what an important uh
Victory you took down the world champion
you took down the Challenger as well how
are you feeling right now yeah it feels
great
um John it has a very solid reporter
with black so it's really difficult to
get the game even against him so I'm
really happy with this win and it
improves my stun my score in the
standings that was in fact my next
question I said at the beginning of the
show that is going to be very difficult
to take him out of his opening
preparation but you definitely showed
your intent to do just that early on
with this like D4 Knight F3 E3 the coal
system uh very cagey stuff Bishop
it's reversed Queen's Indian and
it's a
it's not anything special but it's
interesting to get a game at least I was
happy
um of course black is okay around here
and
and he also seems to be playing quite
some challenging lines Bishop G4 like he
doesn't shy away from yeah it's not easy
it's the most concrete yeah there is no
concrete line maybe there after Bishop
he played the best line actually and
Bishop G4 is the best move probably yeah
and yeah probably he must hope he should
have played better around here maybe
instead of Bishop C5 I prefer A5 for
instance
to prevent and then Bishop takes is very
very equal but
um yeah of course he played like this
and I think I have H here I was maybe he
was thinking about sure she was losing
probably
first I was afraid of this but I have P5
here very important
is B5 is the only move we didn't even
consider it yeah it's kind of funny move
yeah yeah that makes sense yeah because
B5 and then B6 check B takes his son
with a bit of a new Queen there yeah son
he didn't have this tactic and but he
played amazing greatly here I think
yeah my knight C4 probably is not
accurate but I wanted to go directly
here yeah to see what happens
and yeah he played Bishop B2 Knight G5
yeah here Knight G5 was amazing move I
missed it very well yeah because I
blundered in my calculation these
King G2 Bishop G4 Knight D6 I was
calculating Rook D6 B5
but
yeah I missed this Knight E4
and if you take with the bishop 54 he
takes takes check and E5
oh that's nice that's the only way that
he can I think he has another way to
make draw instead of 94.
that's a nice line yeah yeah beautiful
um but yeah it was interesting 95 and
yeah I had to go for an 86 and this
position is probably equal
but he has to be still a bit careful I
think because he loses the opponents he
loses upon he doesn't have any other way
95 queen of four I'm better
so in fact I think the critical line
here was Knight to G6 yeah Rook C1 Queen
E7 Queen C5
why is the night better on G6 than on F5
ah because it defends the last rank you
could give a check
and takes it so now you cannot do this
because Knight of Faith yeah black is
winning oh okay that's such a small deal
yeah yeah oh yeah now we don't have
Queen C5 so I mean I have Queen C5 for
it's probably just throw
King H2
coinage for it's still very complicated
this is some crazy light yeah
um
computer line yeah yeah no it's very
it's not easy here for black actually
because he's down opponent he has to
prove he's well if not G6 is the only
way out yeah practically is almost
impossible yeah but he played good here
actually for yeah I didn't understand
why you're looking at
um Knight is sure I was planning Queen
C4
oh yeah of course yeah for a human to go
G5 or something
because I've calculated this 92.4 and
I'm probably winning here it should be
six so important
and These Wings yeah
um
but
so yeah he played okay yeah if you don't
see G5 then you have to go okay you guys
discussed a little bit at the end of the
game yeah it was for the ink I didn't
understand so much what he said but it
was about the end game I think that's
the end game yes you can go there yeah
here I think I should go Bishop C3 is
easier to win it was stupid I commended
this move Bishop to A1 just for the
simple fact that this end game is
actually mathematically I think yeah
yeah I felt like it has to be winning
because you get the pawn to H5 first
it's I think it's even this is this is
even winning probably
like I'm sure this is winning no
it's for H5
um because I still could go he cannot go
okay five I take
so this should be losing everything you
have some sacrifices at some point yeah
this could be losing as well and also
you cannot get his King to G7 so it's
important for instance if he gets these
maybe it's
still probably losing
yes not easy he said he's probably draw
here but yeah it was easy after it was
born on H5 and
yeah I couldn't always go to pawning
game and yeah yeah it was actually I
think it's it's it might be a draw if
these two pawns the hng uh pawns are
swapped for the afternoon that's true
and then you have Rook H6 extra Square
he was hoping for this like after Rook
A3 he was hoping for Queen C6 I think
and
to take care yeah this is winning but
for instance
because he cannot get his Rook to E6 but
I'm sure this is true
yes this is true I think yeah yes yeah
this is the best yeah which is quite
funny
uh big sequence of important games for
you and you got the maximum out of every
single one of them even yesterday
against Fabiano uh congratulations going
into the championship rounds as a
co-leader what are your Ambitions right
now what do you think you need to do to
win the tournament yeah um for sure
Fabiano is also in very good shape and
it's not easy to
move
outrank him didn't turn on but I will
try to play good I have tomorrow black
pieces with doodle and we will see what
happens
um he's really great fighter and we'll
see thank you very much for joining us
we'll see you tomorrow
and as we are getting ready to see the
final moments of the game between Rich
Rapport and Bogdan Daniel that we're
going to go on a short commercial break
and we'll be back shortly
[Music]
the St Louis chess club is the Premier
chess facility in the United States we
bring the educational benefits of Chess
to thousands of students across the St
Louis area we also promote Chess at the
highest levels hosting all levels of the
U.S championships as well as high
profile tournaments that attract the
world's best players become a member and
enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments and so much
more visit
stlouischesclub.org to claim your
membership today
the World Chess Hall of Fame located in
the heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why chess's
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 1500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the art culture and
history of the game landmarked by the
world's largest chess piece sitting
outside our front door the World Chess
Hall of Fame has something for everyone
to enjoy including various exhibitions
monthly concerts and much more whether
you are a beginner or a professional
there is something for everyone to learn
here at the World Chess Hall of Fame
enjoy free admission to our rotating
exhibitions in our Galleries and sign up
for chess events family friendly
programming and art classes and don't
forget to stop by our award-winning gift
shop Q Boutique and Shop a wide
selection of Chess related merchandise
for more information on current exhibits
please visit worldchess hof.org
foreign
[Music]
happy birthday
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
hello everyone and welcome back to our
live coverage of the super bet chess
classic and Bucharest Romania you saw it
on the screen as the remaining game was
agreed draw between Richie and dioc for
Richie he was half a point out of first
he was trying really hard today to get
away it really was and that means that
we have a two-way tie going into our
Championship rounds for Rounds eight and
nine coming up but let's just take a
look at the results not yet apologies
in fact let's just go to Bucharest and
Christian and final thoughts
while water around here in Bucharest as
we are approaching the final rounds of
the tournament things are heating up and
as you can see nepo and ding still
cannot recover it is the story of uh the
tournament right now and you know Anish
and Ali Reza today took full advantage
of that with brilliant play I have to
say with the white pieces definitely
piled on the pressure and got the job
done and this is exactly what you need
to do if you want to win this tournament
alireza right now in the co-leading
position with Fabiano caruana definitely
must be feeling good about his chances
of at least a tie break but you know
tomorrow is going to be a big day
because we have a big clash between
Fabiano and a very uh in shape Anish
giri and
booming with confidence because he just
won against the world champion so
definitely an interesting Clash that
will be in I'm looking forward to call
all the action with you guys
Christian and once again let's just take
a look at our standings with round seven
in the history books right do the honors
two call leaders now Fabiano caruana and
alireissa Russia welcome back to the
Grand Chester uh Ali reason and then
with four points following Wesley so
anishikiri and Richard record
the people at the top
with a
50 michelleograph and with three points
young Crystal of duta and still can't
believe I'm saying this but with two and
a half points
tied for eighth and Ninth and let's take
a look at what tomorrow has in store for
us
we have mvl playing duck
playing record
oh my gosh the chance the last chance
ding's got to write the ship this is his
last one he's playing his second at the
world championship good point of course
that is true and uh we have two leaders
playing each other carwana against giri
right Nepal Mish against West Lisa great
match and Duda against firosha wow
everything to play for as we go into our
Championship rounds VAR uh I can't
believe what I just witnessed I mean for
me Anish is win today was a career
defining game I mean I just thought that
was a incredibly incredibly good game
and well we don't need to see we don't
need to see this do what you are I mean
wow your mdl I mean you're doing some
chances yeah yeah no darush and uh
Christian are absolutely killing it at
the moment uh but uh final thoughts
about this very eventful I absolutely
big day and a huge win for alireza but I
think Anish played a fantastic game for
me this is the game of the tournament so
far it was a great sacrifice it wasn't
clear but he just developed his piece he
put the pressure on and eventually he
forced dink to make more mistakes and
won a very very important game here and
I would be a little bit worried facing
an issue seems like he's in great shape
he's in good mood and a big game
tomorrow against Fabiano and still two
exciting rounds to go it's hard to see
who will be the winner of this
tournament so very exciting to see the
last two last two round guys yeah let's
just take a peek ahead what we can
expect I hope we have the pairings for
round eight because uh these
Championship rounds are going to be
really really fun as we know it's Anish
Gary versus Gary once more four and a
half versus four that is the that's so
big that I can't emphasize that enough
Duda versus farrugia
don't do that and won a game right not
yet nope he's in minus one right so for
Ali Reza might be thinking hey why you
Fabi have a very very difficult match in
front of you I
he's with black color I know that's
that's the thing well everything to play
for uh in the super bet chess classic
most definitely we certainly been
enjoying doing a commentary thank you
Nancy it's been really good great great
great calling all the the action with
you and VAR and Christian
from the St Louis chess club and
Scholastic Center we're going to be
signing off and wishing you all a very
good afternoon good evening see you
tomorrow see you tomorrow
[Music]
thank you
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited